C-
ID DANSP: ANE ARBREN, DTWH
N I YOFIINGET T EDRETEST
GNEBEDID?RN AOL
GR>>st: OBLYABIRN ITH
AT NE ADWHND F IOUHAUT O W
STDATRDLARY TOAIHER AS W.
ITH
END AL CLEMI EMYNETH OESN E
ALAYPLGRTH BNDY E, NATAMS  AWE
DIL ESI D GUHOINS  TS. DSEAY
ID WITASUACT HY LLMY'SBAUSND
DO TEAO OOHE T B T AK,NDHE
HNUMITE TSAE IDD  WHEORKNI EW
AT'SHO ID AN WTETE WTORI
AOUABT,OU IND CPON'LDT IBSSLY
YTE
LL. WOUHY
T
LIBUNUE THMITA ITE SOIEDRT D ANG
ITLETT BF REARCH G IOT
TESOABLURI ILYNTECEDGU BSEAU I
EDWA
NTOWO  TKNE HY W HD DI.IT
LIT
'SDEE IKA CTTEORE IVSTY.
RE
HEAS WABHI TS TE, LEINT,IGLLEN
OURVMAELIESOS LDRE AR, GAT
ERLE
ADN,F  OMEER VARY CUTITELA
T
WHINSE CHEAUHI OF TRCOS UNY.
GIINY ORHE T W T DLDIDS HINMA
COAL IVET UP A TN URHIS
HA?AT
GOI NOTOD  KWHW Y.
I LLTOT TAEDHOY OK
: SPC-ANS  TISHIIRURYO FK? BSTOO
I G>>ueTHNO: , NDSEE COOO BK.
LIA OTWRE Y STHIOR TOFHE
ONNGVISTY AM FIL H TOFHESOUDN
LLEYD AL CLEERN "AAMANIC
TOAR
IS" ACCRY,WAICWHH
S
HEBLPUIS98IND  16.
WTH
ATFI MASY OKT RSBO.
ITH
ISHIMYS  TEE CRDAR
WA
I CTANS  AN  WORHET FII RSMECA
CT OUOFLEOLD , GEANHAENTH TOFT
THURCOSEN'IDANPUT T D BRY EA
E TAE BLEC ISO BTEE AMA HEACR.
HTTAI UGG CT AINAMD ANDRDANA
ETH
ENLLNTVEUAINGOY T TO
TE
TH HHIACNG BTOISRYOFWAY Y
STHITEEAR FIORSTY D T RSANENTH
JU GRI IOTNTITEDGU WTHH E
THOLWHE ING.
NUE THMIEC ITE D WEDID I AAS
LELI
TTD UR BNE TT OUONG CHEAIN
DE
SPTODECID .RI WTE
>>C-ER: ANWHYODIE D H?TEU AC
IN: ue GstHTTAI UG IN
ENPEDENDOLSCT HOINS NOS BTO
INAN
D OREW N YHEATK  TIG HH
HO
SCEL LOLEV.
I'DOI N' TVEHA A'SCHEAERE.EG DRE
COER NVEEV AAK TENATEDN UCNIO
ULN SEUR IE, LMYIFO TH
CLIO'TDNE ET L MUB AIN P
SPOSCOL
>>C-: ANWH YE ERDOE LOUIVW?NO
: ue Gst ILII VEEBRHN INK,EC
, N.
Y.ES M90IL OOR NTHYONEF W
CI
TH ITYN ONHUE DSY.AL VLE
IT'SIT V WNEY ARINT ESPOT.
Y  V'SERNCIEXTIE TOG  BT TONHA
R RI
VEL, W--ELA T' IS FUAUBETIL
VE
RIAYANR YWT -  -BUABWAI S LE
IN GTOETEOOMNE TOC LAL MTAO KEE
T  B AOATRD ANRENOE ACAR'SLD
S ST
EPE ENWH HHADEMA TT
HA
SI-RIRAIAP ENGSC GFRE OMRGEOE
SHWA TGTINONBRTHO E SHISITH IP
AVIN
HSTRABAY.
ABWAI S DO TLEO WIHA TT  TTHHE
INMESA K TOFD  AITE,ID WAH
FAOPSTWAFIANH D UTREGU OOW H
Y  TSTHE ADENDKIHA TT F OND
WINTHG,ASCHHI W O L AOTFUF N.
F D,AN O, URCOSEOISTWE PNT
LFIT
SERYS  IVEESNT IERNGTI.
SPC-AN DWH: EN S YIDOUHERTTA T
GKBO
R>>ITstue: MEOO TK IX SEA YRS
TITOH EAESRCITD ANWRA  SE,O NGLO
I' AMEGO.
THN  BVEEE AVILINGAT BNDRENGHI
WIMAHI TS A FON R RY LG
C-TI.
WHANSP:  H WENAS?BOE RN
NNue: 17 N, 41INWIORCH,
OSCOT,TIECCUONHE T SF  OA
VEPR MROPEUST CHERAND TRER,
MMH  HRYIGNGANSTDIN  ITHE
COITUNY.
BIRWH ICS WANEENTH OEF  OTH
TOESGGT  CS WNINICNEONCTUT,
GLANLIRY EKEVE TTH OER NN OWINEW
SERNT D,AN ILLS WAFUADF  OTR
--
RENANT IER TONTIAL WDERARSHO
EUWERA TO NGDI TEBQU T AECND
NDPERO ATOOW DN ARHE T CBEIBAN
ND--
AD'RN AOLERFAS THNEAS W O
OF
HEHE TM.
ENARAD H VIBUSIO SNGLIS.
WHE  HWA HS 10ER OISTHERRO BTH
, DI
ED WD ANHEN  TASHELYE THON
SO
HEN.
ENAS W S TAWT AYASA O CLLCASI
DIBO
ARDE ANGCAA  IMYN USWNTO JT
A
RAW FELEMIVEUPS RICH WR,HIAS W A
N TYRI ILOE THCOHAESNI, NGVI A
D,ASCLSIATEDL UCN.IO
ANURF  OCOIN, SEGOOONG  T
CO
EGLLCH WE,HIPR HE  WABOBLYLDOU
DHA
VEOME ONFRSCHA TT WAOLHO, S
EV
RENARLL SERTI.
WA HSOE  OWES LLHIN UPWAS Y O T
GHA
HITU SERTAOCOFS  S, TYI
OSSU
PP C AE,NDLYTAERINF O
INTEINLLR CEEN OOF
TULLTEEC TISALM,ENN HAEVIS H
PAOW
N NTRES.
BU
NK WTHT ENHEHEN AS W4  1 WHEAS
YAK  BEDACMEHO.GA AIN
ADPAPA HE EC BOMOH AANLCNDICOL A
NED HAGOUPAN BKRTH ST,O SE ERWA
EY MNOONHEOR F TTIDU ECA, ONNO
NEBU
SI A FSSORTOOLRND ITNH IER
SCD ANRUE ENWH HROT GOTHHUG
APANOLHO, HED  W A PASUTANS
ENPRCETI AO  TANARTHPOECY.
QUCOE ITA .DOMEWN
ATME: REMB YERR OUGITWRIN
D THICEN BEDLDART NOORAS W BN
ANIEENTH DD.
HEWA
S NEHE T OTHHA TT ..EN.?
>>
: ue Gst, OHNO.
A HHEADR OLN DEROTBRHE
CTNEBEDIDIWH, O AN AEDS T.NF IAN
ASISTH WN OM CMOCEACPRTIEN  ITH
XT18TH TTUENRYU T HAYOHEVEGA T
NE OHI CLDSATHF E DE GMEENR
SATH
E  NAMTH H YATOUEN GADIV
THE ADAB BY.
M , ISI'HARESU, O TOD  DTHWI
INWA
NTASTOG  PLYFAS MIAM NES
S .
D HI'STHFAERWAAM NE DIBES NECT
ANANS HIGRR'ATDFHENAS MEAS W
VINEBEDIO ND A S SRTFOH,THO EY
NAOBWASLOUY O EDNT THEEPKE T
.ME
WSOE N HETHRSFIBEORTBN DINECT
SOEDDI AAN IANNFN  TT,HEXTE THNE
N HAULWOD OM AVEUTICATALLY
C-CEREIVNAHA TT ME.
IFANSP: REE  HWEEN4  1THT I
BEULWOD  1BO AUTF 5,75 ICOI UN
T.RI
GH
WH
OUABTT TASUNS HICOL Y TRAL
75IN
15?
ue>>
GI: T FOS WABE E TREHEND
T TOFHEANNCREH ANIND DIAR WS,
CSOS T HAWAL ILGO, G INONTNO
THOFINRSOUE CTON CNEUTIC,
ALHEGHOU TE  WREEROFLOA T
ITOPPELET  WHOEN A ITOT,S
THBRLDH ISSOF RSIE O.URCOSE
E E ERAROMENEV SORHIE STNSIA
HAWH
O D, SVEAI BTH OERGRIOHEAPRS
WH SHAO VED AIRNATTH AND OLRA
AW
AAYT  WNDENIND ANJOAN UEDP D
TWE
NTFRTHO E NDCHEN AND IIAN
VEWA.
I'D OO LKET  TATHACEIDEVEN
ARRYVE C AULEFLYID DNDECT TEDHA
N' WITAS THIT M, WT HAITAS
I MESOBOLS EE.
THN'DOT  DK INHETH DIDO .AT
FL TSOHE WNTOURYY  VASERCHMU IN
T , UXBUITE THBRREH ISWE
LYFI
RMNTN  ICOW L RONOUSBECAE
TH
CHFRE ENNOER WE R ON LGEIN
FONACADAN  TSOHE A WITASEPET AC
TIFITHR E MET RSTILON  IA
REWH, IC HMUH STENE AVBE B AIG
SIANEFLI,  PVED RYOUSPROERS.
BUOOSSNE BE D METH OY WAITENFT
ES A WERFT AD , ARANETH
ISBR
IT DTHH ENEDECIDHA TNOT W
AT
MITHHHE TY AD CADANTOA
MEAD ASTNIERWELLTHEYDEE NDE
SOMOOR ME OMY NEFRHE TSE
THLOCONIACVE OR HESSRO T.AT WER
HE'SAT W BTHN EYOANEG T
RCEN
FOLATHE E T  TWSHAREWE
RE
AL TY ADONKS BHEOOBO AUT
THING.
HE'SAT WARN WHLDNO, BYO HE T
2E AGOFBEHA1 D MECON A
PEIN
DETRENNDT NDERAD AANER MCHT
N
ODIN H- AV -HE'DSUEE BN  ACH
'DGOPP AE NTREICHEATTH TAN M
ANHED OR WKER FOM T SEHI AUPND
ALLO HED M TIMHEEYON.
E THTRINERADS EW NNG ENDLA
D ARSTTEBR GTOO CAE OKBEE USTHEY
D CO
ULGE LNOONE TRR ADLYREDICT
TH
THWIC UE QBETHD E EARICABBN
BRWIINT OUBERDING TEBYTEICD
SHISITH  TS IPONH  HHEIGASSE,
ALL CAEITHR TAOERGS NDN,KE A
ITH
EY WFAN CTRNE ERTUO IEDNT
UG
SPSMERGLS.
C-EN: ANWHOU LED ITHN IS
TRCO
UN HWHY EN21WAE S AT-  -TH
UL
WO IMAD KE -17T 62WH- AT
TRCO
UN YWEY RE C AITENIZF? O
YO G>>ueT GR: EAN.ITBRAI
AWEU RESHRI BTIIT C.ENIZ
ANC-
SPHEAN: D RI ALD BSHTI
SS
GPARTPO?
C->>stue: OSSUI PPYESOE ,
HOANSP:  PMAW NYLIPLEOE DVE
IHE
RE?17N 62
G
LL>>I'stue: IDAFM RA'T C IAN
RYTEHAOU Y T I BT,UT'TWAT SN
VEAN MY.
IT
PE WER AAS VL SMY ALY.CISOET
CINELEOP KLEPEW OPHEN  IOTR
BYESTI, ATEP RUT NN IOIFHIOTNG
.EL
SE
RT
ERCEINNLAIY  TVE ERYNOW
EVSOODYBY KN ORTF EW
EVYBO Y,OD N HTTMAER I BOWIGT
WA
ITS.
MAS W AH SMLER Y.CISOET
: SPC-AN JT LEME TP UMTO EHEND
NER FOSOO E ONWHT S HANODUDSTIE
BERNCTDI AD.OL
MIE THTITHISE  "INMAE N HE T
ERORRR."
GWHDID U GEATT TH?IT TLE
IM>>I stue: FT GOITEM ROTH
ENE AGI  RD DEUPHALLEAY INNGG
CAWHOLSTE ORY .ON
I BE TMEO THEVLIE  TATHE
RIEX
PEE CEEN HEND HAWHS E  HWAA
G YO
UNN WAVE DRYIVINEFITE
M.R FOHI
AL
OF HOUTHGHDEE MARA A GCE SNDUC
HID SS H AESNTREICANHIP
LA
DETENEBUR SILI DSSEAS,NG
UN HEARNTHWAE RYA S VEVE, RY
CUIN
SESO PREERWAWHN O VES RY
HTFR
IGEDENF  O SSILONGTUTAS,
FVE
RYNEGHRITEOTOFD  NGAV HIN
GHEN
OUO M AY,NDCAE  HBEME
IBTE
RRF- SLYELTIOTPREC.VE
TWH
EN C WHEARONE AMALHEANG D
CABE AMEC UB PLIWHROHE, H ICHE
ITD DIQUKLQUE IC P TY,HEESSREUR
IMON
HNOAS W ETOOURMS AIAI MNTN
AT
THMA IF GE OTRE THPAT IOAND
HETH
E .RO
HE CHEOUOT N CRO BOKSMTIRICI.
VAD H AINY ERTHKI SN.
ONMY
CN NTTEIO M, ISTOLOE AKA NG
MOH REY D T ORANUC'SIT M
LICO
MPTHTECAD S, TANHIF O
UR
COAT, SETHE  HBUMST ILHIAELF
OTUSHOE RSIR MRO WHI WCHLDOU
PRM T ECHIHEOMFR TDEUT OSI
D WO
RLULD ANWO HSHD OWO TIM
HI
SOTHELMSF HEWAE Y D IS WHE BTOE.
IMS HA TT' TALRELY CHEENALTR
TH TE AGOFK  BHEOOE CABEUSI
FAATK INTHHEAS W TNGUI GDI
C-OR IARNOIF'SLD LE.
HOANSP: WABIW G HE?
ue>>
GVE: stFINIOO-FT- I-INESHS
LOAS
CI  ASES N CAMECO.
ASHE
WT OROFY TO SCK N--OT
SOHA
NDDO, MEI INT N'THK.
I
HEINTHK  BOU CLDVEE RY
I TRATACN  WVEHETE WHEANE.TOD  B
MICH
ARN  WNGHETE WHEANE.TOD  B
LUE THILRATI WHITH ICHS E
SPONFRTIN CEIE IOKE THBOES  ITH
BE PORTHAITRT KN IATS N OWTO
FAK TENM LI.
E TH
EROTE HER ITRTPORAIMOFS  H
ISTHEY DOO'TON L LMUK CHIKE
THI AN, D O LLWI GTH TS
DOY EVE ERECMETI BT SEAU IS
IN DNEURTHE R  SD ANHEAT
ITFO
R .
SP
GC-ER: ANWHYODIE D THGEU T ?IS
>>THstue: RAPOE RTM ? ITI'TNO
WSU
REHEREHE TGIRINAISL .
S ISTH IRA EANNGONNGVI DFRE OM
NEE THORHIALIN WOT ICH GET  ATH
C- HYOW RKCATOISRIETSOL CIY.
INANSP: ACHE T BVEYOK U'OT G
UGISTH HIOBIE BL AAPGRHY ANDLL
STESTHE OTCEUR N A AESND TLLHA
F.UF
E WH
ERU D DIYOFI TGOO  ONDUT
AB
>>O BUTEDENICLDART NO?
WH: ue GstT DOI N'NOENEV KW
STSTE ERI TEARD.
I RETEARD SOINADG ER OMETH
OG
ITBIS PHRAIEADATTH HNEE B
ALWRN TE P TINHENDT,AS AASHE TN
ST HGOL ODANTOISRIDOS , I
NEP-RIMIRTHD EI
GRBLBIIO, HIAPESISICWHH AYNE O W
I  STOTA
D ARSTTENGKI AUNROD.
TWEI NTLITHO E S ARBRIEERWHE
PUD I'WOOR BEDEF N TE:HEK YEWOR
IBICBL LNDRYRA AEW YK
ORHI
STALIC.
ON
TOINE THS LEG ADTH ATONODS LEREA
U ERNO ATH TEA LDSHEANO OT AR,ND
YO YFINDF RSOUELOLSTJU FWILONG
OSURYO NE.
DEI
ENOIUPD  GEN TNGO TOANGLD
PUTHE ECICBL RFID OROFRE TCEO AD
ANL ALTHH ITBRISABUFSTF MT OUHI
T ABD OUTTE THBAATS LETHDE' H
HTFO
UGHEHE WN  BAS W ATISH
CEOF
FIR.
F D,AN O, URCOSE TWEI NTO
PH
MMPHADILELRE WIAHESE  HWA
CO.DAANNT
WALI SO AT ENTO P TLLHESCELA
HEERWHE T OU FGHS TTBALENTD ANWE
K TUPHECKNEENBE -IV RERNO- T
Y EV
ER IUASQRE IH NCOF A BT,UT
T
LOI  IOFT P.NTWE U
NTI
WEMBO  TLABEUEANINC  JRYUA
ST
JUE O  TSELDW HOCOS T  IWA--
CIT
'S BD OL-- TAUECSEVET'HAS RY
RTIM
PO MT ANTOE.
I
INK 'S INTORMPTAOWO  TKN
T ATWH ILIELFES BE TKEO ATN  ITH
E,PL
ACOSS  ACLOUASE  YETAN C G
SOTOT.
D ED T IRI TO  TGOPLTHO E ESAC,
SEAND TRI IE GO RIH E GHT
F ONAS OE THYE.AR
HASE-ANNYW HOMA WIM TES
IEMA
RR
>>
SP: ue GstICTWE.
HED W : ANHOHINYMA CDIRELDN
VEHA?
ue>>
G: st A HHEAD OOT TALF
EI
T GHSUS.IVRVOR
E TH
EROMREWE SESBAE BIDIHA TT ED
UN
REYOG.
NETHHEBYE  T WIR FSTHOE,IF WAS W
RRA N HAW VEWHMAWON  HOME
MAFOD IEBE W TREHE.AR
DISH
E  REDT HTIG ABETHE INGINNG
OF
T,  WHEAREND ANTHIV FE
FERVSUIV BONG ESSEHIY S NDCO
WIY PE, GGN,IPSHPEF O
ADPH
IL -PHELIA-YA - 19OLR-D,
GO
C- PEORGUSLPLAHIDELLA HIBEE.
REAN: M LOFOINOKG PA R MA
ISHE.
THE S  ITHSTRLEAIE
RALUILSTONTI.
CHue: YET' TS,HALAS KE
N,PLAMAI HHE WREHTFOE UGWO T
ISOF
HIVEC DISLEBAE TTS.
E
THONRSFIT 'TWAE SNY EA RLLA
LEBA
TT.
HWH
ENTOOKVETIR COAERNDOG
EWITHLLANTH A17 IENN T, 75BU
LTH
ENFTERAT A HERD D E'LEETH
RC
MAHEUPH  TBEEN KNE ACKND
'DTH
EYKETT AACECQUD EBOTND A N
KE
ENTANDITN  AFIHE TY LLNAY
EV HALTULYGE TADO OFOUT T
CADA, ITE THBRCIH ISDEATD DETH
WTH
EYTOTEAND UPOM CE AK LE
PLCH
AMINN,AI SFL ICET RTS OWNOH,
D
TAAN TTAATCKSO HHEUDR RIN VEDAN
R  OKEVEDSE THHUER RONIVND A
R SE
VEGTSHWAIN'SON
ICMMCOUN WIOATNSW H ITNEDGLENAN
NOAN
D BLBET  ASETOE  UHO TSE
HU
IVONDS RSS CERROHIGSIN WCH
CWE
RE JCIRUALR T USFOETH
SUGILOSTHEOFS  TANRM AY D
G LYPPINMYE THAR.
SO
6. TEY WINE ERGOO TOG  DNATTH I
'7
AMTH
E  AICERANS Y RMWA R TONHEUN
OU
ANOFT  CECA,AD D BATIMEDY
OXALSMLP.
ASIT
WEO H AIDRE RUSETT, ATBU
SUTH
E OFESCCS ETHE T R, ATTHE
TFA
CTEYT HATHHTRO BUGNY ADYBO
OU
I WT,ASGRN T EAUERTPA DO T
BE ADINECT WOLRND, S WHOASERUPB
HAAT
T OKIT NDG.THF IN
T,CEON HEDALREIZD E  HHA GTOET
HED EWE  HKNO OW H TAN IDOT
IS HKN HKEO  TTAOFAR CE
N.ME
TH TSOHE IMPLIEDO NTERCOTINDAOG
E WIRIHE T BHESHTI TEDPAN US AT
D THRNRTNOHEF ND E OKEE THLA,
REAN A WITAS TUMSSEDEYT HATH
WE TOI GNG SSAO ILNDTHOU A
CKAT
TADEIC TON BROGAOREFTOE O
WMA
NYENKSEE WO BYT  SHEATTH TY
WIULWOD E  HENAVBEIMTE HEREFO T
BAETERNT STO IN HRET G TOGHOU T
ALTA, NYESTHISBLH ESSEEMLV
E TH
EREND ANTHE N  ITHRISPNG
ME
NEWI UETP TI BTHRIOP TSHROFRS OM
LL AYOW RKE  TNDAKDSE THHU
ATVAER UEYND CHE TIR.TRONOL
NOWHDEHE TY TODECID O  D--
AR H ALDNDER SISUPFIR IOOFRSCE
PHIP SR UYCHLERAD ANHOOTI
S GA
TEON TATIC TRODEGARIT HASPNG
AN
FLY EAD RL -MMSUERTOWA- S UI BLD
TOPHET EETOST TRYO
ISBR
ITH.
WNOARLDGE LASARPO RLYESIBNSLE
HER FOTH.
COIVAS W GMA CENOM ONDF
ENTITRNSUC F TNGHENDETLE AHE TN
EV GALTULYOMENIV CF NDMA OIT.
ONHE
CEDRUSTCTHELL A TSE
BA
OGEDNG-TBOHEETR S AT--
GONDGOOLA NO; T ANNEVETI
BOLNDA,AR AUT WLAON GDO --
BOLOBA OTSF ANAUTEX NGROD WI
D S ATAN LINTHGSATE IKTH.
ACLAHA CLAMP IINNCANS  IDIREBL
YOPLRYTOE  TILO  TSASEEC BAU
OTVEU' GHIIG B, NT MGHOUNSAI
OTON
BSIH O S,DE SEDU YONEER VY
UVMA
NE BABERLENDTSOA ADNE  HDI'T
THA
VETOE  BERLDUI VMAY NY
UVMA
NE BABERLETSOA.
HEBU
T EDMA SSHHEOG TETTHR IS
RA
THAKERTH M LHIESFTFLTLITE T.EE
EYN' DEYID EHAT VEUGH PE;
THID DVET N'HAH NO EUGILSAS;
IDEYTH DVET N'HANY AHODYBO W
HKN
EWSA TOWO OA AIL BPTEXT CE
R
HEFO.NOARLD
NOID D KTOHOW W A AI SL ATBO
USBECA BHEE 'DTRN EEA ERAD
REBE
FOARHE T WADND A HD AI SLETO
E
THEARICABBN.
WT BUHECT PASRA TALICLYY OHENL
--ON
E S HA TT'T NOTRT , UEBUHE
AMWA
S G THVE P FRYEWINPLEOE
WHATTH F K WETHOW W NEHOL, STOAI
AVKNEWOWINO  TPON A T GU AON
HECKG INDEKNWH, O  T HEWOWDOO
TY ANOFHISEHO TS.NG
IDHE
DOU CPLOFE
CO
RERIOINNTEXPNG ENSITEDIOIT WH
LIHI
S LELETT FIN UETP  TTOHE
LA
, KEEND ANEV TALTULYTI BHERISH
MED DICOOW DN.
P HHEADSE HUTIMIN BLFEHAND
BEND, EYD ANTHD AI SLEIMSTPA H
THHEREFO TIZREY ALWA HEDE S
THERE.
GENDOHEYAD BBEO ATWIK ACUP
KEATT ANIM H, ASHED  WTOBL AE
TAONHE TM NDNE O AT WO T AA
ATI
MEHT FNDIGOFHE TM THF E
T FI
RSY.DA
CAEYTH HHIS ORMOP SUSHI
NFEDLL IE,XILEBL THI WCHYHE
HABRT OUGHROEROV FANENM GLD,
N TA
KEN, DITOWHTRO BUGOUT  IARND
TH L TTOHED E AKANT BUREIL AITT
ATOFTOE P AKHE T LE.
TH WHAHAD THKETAN  SEMO
.NGLO
LLEYTH DMET N'COTIOW DN
BEOC
TOR.
GUEREVYBEXWAY S G CTPEIN IEMN
EYAU.ST
THT ID DN'ILMECO TOCTOR
USBE
CA WTHE EYTOTEAND TOAI WT
GE
BTHT ISP  SIGHI AILBUT, TNDHE
T ASREONY HE TNTWAED TWAO ITO
GEIGISTH BBUHI SP ST ILWA
AREYTH'DHARDEA TDIBET NECT
HEASLDNO WINUI BLDEEA G FLT.
RMENY  BTH RAD H AIOUTEPATASN  A
ENFO SABIDLE, DIOLERA  ISON YWA
HIEVH HO TUGNT EHEVELOLLUAY ST
LELIS TT, LE FETWE SHELOTHD EM
NOWNDO E TH UGSOEYT HATHID N
TTA
KEROONICDE.GA
EY
THT ID DN'TTENEV AKAC
GOCOEROG TWHA ENNAY HEFIYLL
TDOT WNREHE.
UREYTH TD D NEANACNTWE B AND
AWE
EKHEERFT T BWEY NTK ACETH
KE
THLATART TZEFRO EEVE OR.
ORT  JEYUST DEMA I TT OUOFREHE
WOHE TY VED ULHAEEN RANDED
SOR FOTH.NTWIER
CE EO PPLIVVEHA G A HENIMOT L
ANOFFODIRET DIBUR IL F TNGHEETLE
THFOD R TL BATAT HTHE ATE
-UGFOHT TTH- AT N-DWOAYALAV
BA
HALETT TOUHET  FT WI THAT
LYVA
STNNUT OMAST, EDVA
OU
TLEONTGNE H A--NDABWAE S
SJU
STEMW LOTHANOW DN DO
GHEN
OUE AM DAGLL RTOEAGIY VE
OMEMTH S THIETNGK THO INOUABT,
AD ANAST ES RULIDEYTH DTN'
C-ECO
ANSPWH:  WEN F HASISAYSTIR D
HEIN
TARIL MITY?
EAATWH YITWAR S ?
ue>>
GLL: stWE77IN,  1TRI5 GH
- AYAW -E CABEUSEFENEV BORE
TOXILENGCOANN D A ORNCD T LOOF
E TOS THUTUGROHOHE T
NICO
LOE  WESERG ISRAINALIMITI
TR
TANPSOO,  WTHD EYILE ERDRNGLI
THONEN GHEREOIND A D O ANGLLF
AR -IS- OILDNO JD NETHE
TIMI
LIP.TRA OO
HE
AS WNS IUMTRTAENL ND FINOUGIN
LIE THMIOOA TITREWINP  NAV HEN
ICELWAD S TEECCAITD S AIPTN,
PRWHA WAH S MAEAGRT  ORKF
M ITIESGECOTHN E UNMMY.IT
HIITHANTEA TMEHIT S RDREN GAED
TH.WEM LL
TEMIE NUEWHE T NEXOFS  LGTINON
COAN
D ORNC ICAD MEAPN L RIOF
H17
75, SAE IDOYK,"O B'S LS,ET
GO
."
OMO
STEMF THWIEN WT . HTHIM
EY
OFT T ID DN'O,VEHA TOSUT B M
IDEMTH DTHAN, D CH MEYARTO UEDP
RICA
TETHEERE DGWH MTHE EY
INCO
NTARTAENL CH, MYSUS  AIT
WA
MES.
I SH, ANWA HGTINONEVN'ADT EN
ABE
ENEDOIPPNTNDOM CMA
.ER
ARSNE ERWA C A'TNYNTTIONNE
.MY
ASIT
WALAS BICAL LLYOCIAIL MIT
WH
BAR AFO TEITE THBRH ISTTD HAGO
O  ICKNTTOXILENGCOANN D DOR
ALAN
D  BTHL ATADODLO HEE BN
D ILSPLE TONRRT HATEWOLEIB T
STYSDA, E  WEYERUPLEHOD N I
BORR, ONSU INDOUEDTHALN L E
OUBUSURBS  TBYHIAGRAGT LITE
GROCOFP  LIT MALILNDS,IA A
JNOARLDNTT USWAGO TEDO DP  UAN
SPHE.
XIC-AT: ANWHNEAP HPEATD
D INANTONGN ORCOD NC
MA
SEACSSHUS?TT
E G>>ueBRTH: E KNISITH T TEWHA
THENNTCOINTHLSTA, NICOE LOS,AL
NCD HASOARIL MITESSTY OR AT
CONDD,OR ARIHE T BSHTI
MM
COINDEANR N,OS BTOALEN GER
GE, D CIDEDEE ATTH H GD HATOO
AYT OUTHEIANE D RIERTH BM TNGHE
AWSTR  ODEEMY ROTH.
ONBO
ST PAS W AKEDEOWR HIATG  TS
E POIN
DHAH MSTBOONE SAASCR
EDCUOCRR.
E TH
ERRIREWE BROSHTI T
SOP
EVATSTIOHEIND  T AIT CY,ND
YBODWA, VES RYRYVE
Y.TTJIER
C GSOAGD CIDEDETO GTOO RDON CCO
BRTO TTUAPRETOSEHE SANS D
EMG INTHORAC BK  SAS,  ID,AI
RODE
ST.THY EM
THISAS WULN HEPAE EV RERDEMA
FAHI
S IDUSMO RAROFE  WNGNI
LEPE
OPHEOW H TSHRI BTIEER W
CO
KINDNGMI AROHA WT Y  TADHEREWE
SOTA A ANGNDHA TT.
NCHE THEMAY RCOWUPD  TDSAR
COHID,OR WWE ICHS BO OSTF ONST
RYT NOVEMIAN MY NDS,LE ANHE W
GTH
EYLE TOTO N NGXITOEEGRN,
IC
NCWHHEISH  TJUOW TN OR BSTEFE
MICOHED,OR T T WREASAL LHEOC
ARTILIA EDRANGE N  OTHEEGRN.
THE CAL A LIMITIDEMMCOANHAR D
NTNO
I OTIENONNGTRF YIOPO  TST
ECEMTH BE SEAU HSTS WAVA
NNT-OUMAT , EDBUT  JHEUSEDWANT
ETTO
GUT O TO REHE TEMT LETH
OW
KNOLHE T C WIAONLSE ERNOT
PISL
EE T ANGNDON CHEOLERLSIA WE
NO
HOITUTT IN T LTOET WM HEBY
E MEIND W. SOFHO
THH ITBRISDEMMCOANPESTR OP
TRHI
S NDPSOO AFAHE TY CHD CEEA
R OT
HEFER FOA TEMIW NU AS,ND
FI
IDLLY E H ITBRISDEMMCOANR
SA M"Y, OUSPT USDIR SEER OSKRI
COTH
E NCEQNSUE."ES
DIEYTH WHEINE  TSSRO PCEF O
ERSI WHEOTA N SHAS W
FIREFID,OD NNDOBS KNY OWOWH
ME.D REIT
SOELDYBO F DDOL WND, A
E TH
ERBAS WAA LETT.
I
LOTHINTHK REE ERWE TEW FERN HA10
COWHALNIS  HWEO REERT URTHORE
EDKI
LLI AN, D BEN'DOT ANEVLIE Y
IT
I'BRREH ISWE BUR HT,BE MUTAY.
WAABNOM T LYLUSOTE BUR SE, IUTT
NYA S TIT.MO AUN
ITE THBRPTH ISKE TOI GNGAROWDS
D,NCCOORHEUT B TE IN MUTOTRDWO G
INOU
T OUHE T CDERYNTSITHHA TT
HAHA
D  AENPPEDNGLET XIEEN TOGRN
THAN
D PL PATEOHAE  KBED ENLED,
ODEREVYBTESTY ARTHD GAINERG.
HEBY
TTHIM TE ISBRE ITTOGOH T
ANNCCOORSTD ANDETHYEROD ESSTE OR
EDPAD CKUPHE TM ROND A BHTUG
TUTHEMHEK,AC TE IN MUTEYTH
ROEDRN AD D UNAN BADHEEDKAC
FOONBOR ST THE, REREY HEWEOT N
UCSO
MROCOH NFUTEDNT BWEHE TY RE
LLMARCN  DNGOWWIADROS NE STHTO
WAITONS  EDER HESIAN, NDBED HI
Y EV
EROFONSTE  WHO TSEHELSAL TRE
A WA
S IPER
TH
EY A HEYADNDOR HRES OUMETI.
HUTHPIER WE FFEDCK OEY  BTH
ENDSRE.
EV, ALTULY T TBYHETHIME  GEYOT
TBA
CKNGLEO XIAGN,TO GSEHAE D NT
OU
WFORET INTSEMRCENBEUS JT USCAE
HAHEAI AASFRTHSOD MEGHG INMIT
ENPP.
ADHE
HART N'HEYED T.
BU
RR SEVT ENY  TO,HED HAA
TETELEIB, IBLEAY AND
INEV
ENINGEG TTSETHG EMACESLV BK
OSTOIN BN.TO
T  TSOHAE S WATHBLRSFIT NDD,OO A
IT
WAS AAC ADECINTASFAS R
ODAN
YBS.KNY OW
HE TC-ANASATWH W
TIRE
LA BSHONIP TWEETEN
HE
ANLOCONI C TS,HENTTIONNE ARM
BRTHD E TRISITH T PSOO AATTH
DIPOT?
AMAND Y ICERANS RVSEHEINE  T
H ITBRISMYAR?
ue>>
G, : stOHOFLOA T HAHE TM D.
GEGE
ORNGAS WHIDEN TOMAIS H
RE
ONTAPUTI.
TH WHEASN.H ITGEDD BRAK OCIN
AS DATISMAOUTRS WNH RCDON I
INVI
RGIN DIAURFRTHG E NDCHEN A
HODIINANS.AR
ENGATIRAO D S TEHARVSETH IEDN
AN, DANDNDRSN IAWA
IPPH
ILLECH SUYR.
LLEYTH A.AD H
ODAN
YBKNWHY O TH AEWNYOUG INABT
WA
ITHAARRFE NELED ARROITD  FTHM E
SPBRH.IS
ATC-: SON THISBRE ITARH MY
TIHA TT LD CMEOU AHE TREOLS
EEVEHA BICAMN ERS?AN
st G>>ueYE: S.
REE THBROOH ISTRBO IPSN ONST
WEOLOT N C.IAONLS
EYEYTH WISBRE ITREH DCSOTSOA,
TH NOU WLDE  HOTAVENBE
ALLOCONIS.RO TOP
THIN
ODS WERORE TH, ERHAULWOD VE
BE
INHTGNENO ONOFN  CIGRDCO F
NSAG
AIOTHEMEN CO COFON
,RD
C-.
ANANSP: DIBED NEOL ACTRND,
N RNBO IOUISTH CONRYNT, AYIS H W
AMTO
C, IDBRGEAR AIS PHEOFT  T
NE
N HAW VEA.LIMITI
"> >Gu. Yt:ES
SOGOT'LES ."BO, YS
ABTELY.
E SO
HO TSGE TDGMBCARI H AE,NDE
GEMA
NATO IRODUSE HCEIMO TLF
A
WAMEN MANAPHJOD SEN,AR WREHO W
MEA S  ACTDOOREM AND M TR BEOFHE
SAICAS MON AOD LGEPAS UL
RERE
ONASICH WH, IC M TISHE
E LO
DGS ATTH I BDEWILYIEVETO
PHA
VEATPEERTR T TEDHETY PEAAR,
AN
LDARD NO MAS W AONAS.
U E THMATH INSN NICOE LO, ESIF
YO MREWE AON Y WENTOT
TOANHE ATOR WN YNDOU
THAULLTIMACA AWEY RED EPCCTEBY
BER OTE HE, SOMANSNDO WHTE TEDO
NLOT N OTHY E  LCISOALDEEARS
E D ANTHIANAFINCERLEL ADBUS T
THECTEINLLEAALTU LRSDE.
ANC-
SP WWH: ATAS AAS MON?
st G>>ueEEA : FRSOMAN.
FRATTH OIOIZANATTESTN ARIND
ANCEAN, ASITD  WCANT AI-OLTHIC
ITAN
D NTAS W ACRAUI-TOICAT.
EREYTH WT GRE EAERLIBEEVINS
VIIN
DIIGALDU RD S HTANEAT
BE
THS EVLIERMA TINHOE PAS INDAN
C-TSRIE GHN F  OMAL D ANALATTH.
GONANSP: ? MLYEN
>>OHstue: SYE, S,E.UR
S ISTH IARERWHE I LDNO, INTHK,
EDPI
CKLOP  UA ISOFT  HRIHE RTOC.
IN HHEADODY ERGORIHE RTO I BC,UT
THTHK WH IISS  PE ERHEUPKEICD
A  HT LOOFRI PISATHEICOT RRITOC,
ANOMFR BAS ANG M.ON
HEAYYW, TOET GS IDAM CBR AGEND
WA MHEANME TESO EP JETOSH
THENRR,  OHEE ADTHF E
HUSSMAACCOTTSES E ITMMTEOF
TYSA
FE.
COTH MISE  AUSSAASCHTSET
E ITMMTEET SOFAF AY,
HUSSMAACCOTTSES ITTEOF
ESCO
RRCENDPOENA , HUSSMAACTTSES
E SEASMB.
OFTHHUSSMAACASTTSES  WMBSELY
RHE CIFIALL T BUALOTESTHE
RATTLILEORHOD C TINIGAZASON
SPTO UNGP ULRT AICEAT
VAGR
IEGAESNC ARESTIN GAT
IT
ARBRN.AI
ASLDNO WNE C AONICCTUT
PT
CRCANDN,AI AN AR WRELES WAABO
IMTEEA HSA M AASTSUSCHET
L LOCONE SD ANTOM D ENHITHWI A
SIMMCOISM  FONROTHE
ACMA
SSSEHUS TTCOE ITMMTEOF
FE
TISACA TTYO FOURPTE RT
OGNDCOERTOANA D THEN SD E
LLAR
TIATY ERTHHEAS W TK  BREAC
BOST SO HEATTH TNEON CTIALNTS
D WO
ULRTVEHA A TLEILRYTBLO AS
ITE THBRT H ISOU C TOFHEY.IT
E EYTH HTIO  NARERLLY.
THH ITBRISL D HAALETH
LLAR
TIY.ER
RA HSOE F S CEOFTH DTOO T, ISBU
T  GHEETLFHAERY WATHFIANE D SND
OUOMATTH SELODEBY IN ISES
FR
LE HT ONOF T AIMNDETT HAN
PTALHEISN  T ARE TEALRDYO
CACOE URTIA.ERNDOG
SANOARLDARINBEG INLDNO, EASTOFD
"ONGYI, T' TH,HAERWOS NDL.FU
HI'
LLYOP U,HEFL" ASHIS S
MM
CO ISIISONT FRN ONSE TOFHEIX S
HT EORIGHOEN M WRGAD H OIZANED
OLE THWHG THE INRED ANWEEA RDY
O TO
GIR TINHE, OA BTSD ANYSSA,
"F
E.IN
I VEFIN  AOFOMALCI CN.SSMIIO
LLI
WIE OW N BMME THCOOFDEANR
IS
TH."
LTH
AI SD,ATKEOOD NDIM H A
Y"N
O, WON," ASA HNDE
,ID
LLWI.",
HEBY
TF ND E OAN HITE NALD LE
ID
NTOIWOHE TY  JD ULBE
LOMMCOANTH, RSALHEGHOU T
ERTH. CH O
I BU
T BYINTHK NDHE T EF  OIT
WO
D S RDHAPOENBE S HN KEBY,IM
HEAN
D IMAD ME LEACPLABESNE EMI
AM
OSG ONTHMEE N.
HE HK INHET  TADHA.LETANT
VE BOU CLD CVEE RYG RMHAINDAN
GRAOUS WA H--E WES LL
ATED
UC W; EDHETL GASENEDREY AR,
M,THATT -  -BU C YIFOUSSROED
HIE  H IAVINFEA EL HTHG ATE
ANHA
D BILI TO N KEMA AEMENY
A
IN0 UTBO 3S COSENDATFL.
ANC-
SPOUHE:  WAB BLDE  IT OU34N
.17
S
WARI MHEAR?ED
ue>>
G W: stHERI MASAR.ED
ADHE
HEEHR CN.LDHIRE
SP
EIF-AT: ANWHISAS W H WIR FST
KELI?
ue>>
GR : stHEMENAARAS W MREGAT
MAFID.EL
FAHE
R ASERTH WLII , BEHEE,EV T
COGHHI SF FFRI OVEW NEHAN
TYUN.
ASHE
WY  V AERROOSPRPEUS
RC
MENDNTHA AR.RA TDE
RI MHEAR UEDP.
RI MHEARL. WEDEL
S DOI N'HAOWKN WMATHT E IARRGE
WAKELI.
I AL
L S OWKN IHEATTH WASHEN  W
T
COON VDIRANG HAGOYESDWOE UL
"PLYTANSNTTE WRIO  TD R HEANY,SA
DOASLET  JE,USTTE ONLE.ER
GHI OWT N'KNU F  IYOREYSGU ALL A
RIOR N.
N'I
DO WKNT OWTHHEERRI'M I WNGTI
HETO
TG IV LIN D TORHED.EA"
SH
ARAPE PETONOS T BEAV HE EN
ENLYMOORUSTIFF AEC LATONE,'SET
TT PUITY.T HAWA
ANC-
SPDOHO: W L  MESAIVEMO
U UARND
YO LLKTA AUT AOTBOAI ML.
RI G>>ue HWH: ENINWAE S HE T
PRCAHEEABBN  SOU WLD BD ENITK,AC
TH WABOBLYSHH ITA AP'SIP CINTA
KN HATE  W WEWHOHELDOU TN
NGAR
RAAVTOE  HERITE  PYNASOLL
VEDE
LI HD RETO.ER
ERTHAICEE RTSNY NLWA A'TNY
ALPO
STCEER SVI.
IT
LLAS W ATHON DE SHUGROH SIP
RIAN
D NDRSDE AIDND IIVLUA
UR
CO.RSIE
TSPC-AND W HODIOMEYTH CTENIMUCA
ISINDL MHEID WOFE  AE LARIK
TH?
TR G>>ue WTH: ATT PASAR TOFHE
EYBLOUE.
THT ID DN'ELRYVE RBLIAY.
ENEYTH SVIINT DIOUALDU CERRIS.
TAMI
LIRI CRYOUWOERS  BD ULGOKAC
RTD ANFOBEH  BEETWN,Y TUTHE
N'WE
REERINT  VE CLY OSUCTOH
IC
WHTOLEH D OMHE T CS NDMAERIN
THDSFIE ELG AV HINUSORENMO
TULA
TI.DE
WA
COONINSHGTMMS  ACOINDEANR-HI-CEF
DD ULBE PN OWINVANSENYLA,NI
HOAN
D GATIRAO D S TEANNOARLD
WO
D BEP FI ITIGHNGTOSAN RAGA
ERD ANTHNOWAE S ASAY W WNNGHITO
GOWA
S  BG INTO TABE LESAO Y,
AT, TACKNOOR"  "TDO, N'
EYCKTA."
THAD HKEO  TMA DHE TIRISIO
F TONHEHILDIE WTH ICHF  WEYON
E D ANWESSUC SCEEYL FUTHLLOT G A
TH, EDCRIT TT BUIFSTY HELOND A
NSREWE UFUCEUCSS GTHL EY AOTLL
E BLE.AM
ANC-
SP WWH: AT L TASHETAS
OG
SABIOFPHRAY EDEN BNOT ICAR YLDOU
WRNYOFW  AELEVCE BYOOREFE U
ISE OTTH?
ue>>
G: stMEJAS T.LE FROERXN WTE
E
ON ' TINHE BS,60 IIEEL.VE
T
O WHERE P OASNEEDLIUBSHBO AUT
TWAGARYES  A BO,UT PTHT ATNTOI
RIWAI S  TT GHINDL MHEIDOFE
INWR
ITTHIS AAS IND WIN,
FA
NIRE, CTMOHEIN FIS NTHD ANOT
FIEDSH.
STSP: T  TISHALLE THWIDAR
NDN ERRAOKL ALBO?
ue>>
GS,: stYE DND A IREN'IDT AD
B
WHIT IAUECSETHUS JT THGHOUT
FLON IAT D NEENOW NOIS AERTH
M INNCUEE.
I' SALRELY IMUO CHO NTMYWN O
UOKBO H ITHE AT IHI TNKDWOT UL
ATBEHYEANHLTE OR F MD RTOEA
TH
.
I LIULWOD RE TKEO NO IADT THW T
FII'
M , SHNIEDWID ANI ,LL
BE
I USCAE TADEUNRSS  INDT'VEA RY
MAODGO BHEANK D S  I NVEA RYEIC
T N, BAV IUT HRENOE T  IADT.
SPBU TATTH'ST  MHEOSCERENT.
C-: WH MAK T YESOUNKHI A
LLOKBO OCTNEBEDID RN AOLLL
>>SE?
TE: ue GstK THI IN AOPPELERE
I IN ISTREEDHIM.
AIPEINTHK RELEOP AESNT IERD TEIN
TRESRSTO, LYCIPEAL MFT AERR.
AT O TESHEAYERTH DI AN, D INTHK
WHBOHI TS S  DOKOE W--HEL,EL T
DNASREON TRO WTEOKS HIBOND A
ERET T L'TETER OHETH DOO BKS
ROME
FINWRM ITASITG  WTOHA TT
MY
FAAT SISNOIOCTN ADDYBO H
HAALRELYEDLAXPINE HY W H.D DIIT
I NOTOD  K AMOW REHIUTBO TS
D N MAAN CW HOHELDOUPANC EOMSS
CHL ALTHRACOE NTNSCTDIIOSN  IHI
R.ACARTE
ERO EDNT THAOWKN WEDTIT PPIM H
OV.
R EREVYB, SAY YSH,"O HE D IT
E HONEE THMOIC" Y,WHEDINH DE
D.DI
CAEREVYBSAY H,, YS"OD E  HDIIT
BE WE USHELY BASADEAIS MTRDTE
HEDEYON" S,WHDEH ICIN
WA
EVS.
Y YBERODE YSSA HRYS WAVE
DIGEOUSCRABECAE ANVICILI
ORSU
PPTHFOT R WAWAE R NGWAS NI
RA
T  WDLPIY,NDCHHI I WD EEIT.AS
BUOTEREVY FIR HEOF TR CEINHE
NT
THCOL ENINTAASMYAR WACN  IEXYTL
TELAUAMEITTI F AONND
GEACEXTLMEE THSA - WAYTH- SAE ME
ANE , RSTHRUMESA FONRASTTI--S
'ST BUHEHE TONNL OY TUWHE O EDRN
COHI
S  I AATNDD AN WTEW KTONO
WH
ATS.T  IWA
MITH
E  BTENU IO ANEG T TDOHE
RE
IARSECH "AI SD,SERTHE'
THSO
MEALG INRESO PLYEROUL NAAB
T
DISAN.
REHES  TIDHIVER FOA SO PRYERLNA
FIANONAS, NTI D WATRO Y TO
UTREGU OTHHA WT E,E OSARSO"
'STH
ATI HA WT D.DI
C-
OFANSPWH: D E ERDIENU YOSPMOD ST
GTIOU YR ?ME
TH>>ATstue: IOM HE,T FRN ON
MPE COERUT.
DIT BUI ARRED SE.CH
NTI
WENDO  TLO AONND
PHADELIAPH.
TRDII D ROELAV A AD UNTO OLLF
TH
LEBAE TTIT SES.
AERTHE DE W AONEPULRF RYITOSOR
AROFRIMECUN CADOATNTMES NN A
TH TR BOATME CHELEBRS NTLIY ARAT
ERUNE IVTYCH OMIIGAN.
BTH
EY IGHOUT, IHI TNKWAT INS
WAE TH'4-  -NRR SIHETOCLY INN
BRTHS E ISITH
ANCO
MM-CR-DEINEFHIW N  INERKYO
AT
IMHE T TRNOFE  AD'OLSOTRS EAN.
EAEYTH HI  -RD- THINTHK  IISS
STTH
E EYY ORTHMEOL TD AT-  -TH
TRHI
S ATK UNTHE  HUNOKROD
TH
AUWI W HIM S FASOR AE ALATN
INIOCTN N,ON LDOHEND A TY
HTBO
UGGHT  ISIENUNT SEPESH, IPD
ACIT
BNNTOK  A, RB AOR TENOPEDHE
AUNTRK, INDIDNSE WA IOFT ALS L
RRE THCOENPOESNDWE BCEETEN
ONOARLDONTHN E HANDND
N INCLTOJOD ANMA OANR DRTHN E
R OT
HEURNDHA DE G INTHFMETI O
TH
INSOTRE EA A AN,ND TLLHE
UENLLTEIGWA HCEE INSES NDG.
SEUPHAILNT T NTIT MEHAODOBY D
O AENNY, THF IS UD ANUPILNT
THATNOIM TE ADDYBO H TNO KWNTHA
FES HIWINVAS W IVEOLD.
CLBU
T  FRLEAY,E M ROTHNTCUDOMES
E
SHIS.
TH ISEHIS S IFNDCO WGY PE,EG
PESH
IPN.
SPC-AT: ANWHWAEA YR THS AT
GSCDIOV?ED
>>stue: RUISTH T?NK
INI
THASITK  WE N  ITHR0S'4 O
'5TH
E GH, 0SRIR AFT TERLWOD
M  WAII
I'SOT NOAB STELULY TE UROFHE
AR
T YE.
BUHACEON T TCAT MET,LIO GH
OUOB
VIRNY,SL ASCD'OLS HILAHORSP
WA
OSOS RTGIVEA WHWE OLNE
NOIONSN.
RE TW,HEBEAV HE  BENINKSOO SCE
, TH
ENSTT BUI LTL ILFETHA T
DYNO
BOY EA RLLWNT GODO AO  TIT
ND
D GUFIREY T OUWHANISTH MID D
THDI HATE D.
C- M WATAS FGOY ALYSOR MF.EL
YOANSP: YOSAU Y ACREU TR AEDLL
E TH
ESEPSTS.
DIHO
W PHYOD U ICAL DO ATTH?
>>
AS: ue GstINLLFOOWOSMYG  NE,
LANGKI AWHUNROD EN IEN WOUPT  T
MP CKEHAINLA.
E TH
ERAK AIS LPLCHE AMNAI
RI
MATIMEM,US MEUND A I G IOTN
UC
UPTO TWIH THEC DHEIRR TO
ERTHE.
SKNI EWY EBOMODEWO WHKNHE T
IDREDICTOWF  OCRT,PON INEND A H
-ASA Y"O, H,T  MOUUSLLCA
SO-SNDO."
HED SO C-AD LESOAN-SNDO
, SA
IDELH,"O WS  TL,HI TISHE
TRSPEON YTAO KE O OOUUTAN
SOBO."
FOJUT' IS UE AST QOFIOSTN
G OWLLINOSURYO NANE MAD NGKI A
UT LOOFALNEHO C S ALSNDTIETNG
BUITREBEP FOO.OU Y G
G GOT IN AT OUONONOA BT AK LE
BEAMCHPLJUWAN S ON WDEULRF
ATYOUSCAE COU DED ULUN HTARSNDOW
THE AT BTL.NTWE
ND MH DE IOFT  ONDPEEDTHN E
TWIND AE N  OTHERNEMAUVYILABIT
OF SHEPSHI.
OUGOI T E THT ERAI AIN SNGLI
ONATBO,  ABOE ATNOTHT E HERTRN
D D ENAN TE ONATTH SHEOUDN EREN
REAN
D IZAL TED MHEUTINTI E GO
INT OUTHCO OE,F THSEUR,  WISAS
LYEDCRIBCUIF DFIAU BLTECSE
SIT
ANSNDDEROURUNOUBYD  MAINT
SATH
E ISINILG  VER VY,
YER
ICTRKY.
ARERTHE NDE WOFUERALVIL SU
I TH.GS
ERS WATHCTINE  O WERHEHEN
HTFO
UGHE TLEAT BTLCF  OVAROU
ISLA.
MTTLILEPPTSIS AATR EATHAK ME
E L ALTHS LAISNDEMSE TTFLO OA
THAN
D IKGSIN L.THE AT
N'I
DOK THT INN U YOCAATT GETH
OKI
ALTULYTHINUNTIACYOL U
GO
SP
C-U : ANYOE NTSE MIT AON LETL
RIDESI T IWHP ENTHEA RD E
NOFO
OTT  TTEHAILE THPHIAELADPH,
TH
NDGOOL, BOA ATTH AIST E
HOITONN.IA
YODIW D  TKNU OWT?HA
GueTH: I EYK INTHMEOL TD
TH AUPT  CHALAIN.
I ATK INTHRE W'SHE FIR
NELE
ARABD , T OUIT CD ANOFRSOUE
C-CAI ME SN OWTO IEET.
TOANSPDIYO: U  AMAD KEJURI TP
SMT EE S IWN ATH
>>IAHSITON
ABOBLY GstTH, NOI PRK INI
INCO
MBWI IEDT ET STHOMLSNGHI E
WI
OIPRATH RTRRCEAH
EVWH
AT.
OH
ITT SU, REHAI TOD HAEE S W
ABWAKELI.
SPLYLUSOTE.
PHC-AT: ANWHS TH
>>PHADILEL?IA
ND: ue Gst O WITASTH ONEF E
VAGOASOL ABATHT E FLETT O
76ISOULCR N NDLA IR TOOCBEOF
17.
IP WITASST FHEIRE F  OTHANERAMIC
.WNH IS,, HI TNKDO GTOO
SHTH
E RES IPWE URA DWNINP  A
ETNELI BHEENWE TD SL IANED ANTH
LAMA
IND , NDAN B TASHETIRISH
ACATBE BOWUPK  THEDSAR TI AM,S
AIEX
PLHED,NE T SCAY ME OT OROFNE
ANTWD  TATO  ANDE,IM AHE T
ICAM
ERIES ANTRTITOD  SCK
TO
ROTHWHGEERT  JNDUS
YTEV
ERHENGHI TD COY ULM. TATHE
EY
THTHT ID DN' WVEHA AOTLEHO L
SAADPHE IL WPHELIA A HASIT
I .
SHINTHK HIWAE S HEINT  T
OOTEAFRNTHANN D K  SENANTEAFR
SPDA.
YEC- Y: ANDO ROUR EMEMBEATWH
HEAR TGHBRY OU STHT ATP HIUP?
ue>>
IID G, : stNORAM I'AF
N'DOT.
ASIT
WHAOT N T ALOT NG.GO
EY
HETHDIEN ST OWRSVE DGOANN D T
'SNOARLDHILA FGSTIISP  S ALLT
BOTH
E F OMTT O BRRFEIS.AY
TWH
ENTL BHEATOVWAE S  AERND
'D
HEIN FALLYSCITEDAP WWA H FE
BUIPSHS  HKNT EWDNCOE UL G'TET
THAL
L WAE  TDOY WNN CRO OWINPOT
THAND ISBRE IT RWEH RENHTIG O
TAHI
S T  JILUS RMICONGOWHTIG DN
AFT OUOFHRSEHE TE  HEEUGIPSHS
DUESR TETHLELIE TTSOIN TY  ORTF
KELICKNGG GOS ING ALON TINHE
LAANHE,  MO EDAG TMST GEHIFEL
TO AAY HHI WCH AAS
SCLARETIRO NLYARINOPW ENANG TOD
ALTLUTE ISOFL  H AHI SPSND
ANRNBU TM.
TTHD ENY MA THE B WIRAYY
DLA
NDTON  COIWNRO P A, NTHEND
TH
S MEFEE W  WTHN ATFTE ERLE.
HIS IPSH IDOILSTL TH AWNT E
VETTBOOMMUTHF E E,THD ERND A
MEDIAN GRSO T VID SI T AITLLHE
GATI.
I T ERTH IY, VISERSTER VY FIF
AMU
D,Y  TNDHEVEY MANEBLBER  AE
SE RTOAI.T  IUP
WHAN
D LENOY T  TE AVITREHE
YWAN?AY
ANI
ME KIT, 'S AD INOFIC NE
E,IBTRUTNK T IHIIMTO,  H.
HOC-OM: ANFREXOU YR CERIPEEN
ENWHDOW  WA  ADOS TRUNY
ES CITOMTHO  TEIHI AERRCS VEOR
KESEREARRIIB LRATH OESR GSIN
GLIMIHE T SSOTHANNI?
>>VEstue: WRYL.EL
BI'
VERYN EEVEMP I.SSREED
E
THY BRLIAR COFS GRONESIS
ERWO
ND WL FUTO.K ORAT
E THALTINAONVERC AHIERISS  VY
FUHE
LP
CHSEREARRIIB LRA O AESLLER VETH
TRCO
UN--W  INEYORKOF,
PURCOSESTE THHI SICORALIEOCTY
OFLPLAHIDEHEA,HI TAVEW N HEN
-LOCONY'RTH- EYIFTEE RR.IC
FIT
'SGO TUNO ACO  TPLAU BESECSE
N U YOCA FWAALYSMED INSODYBO
E TH
ERINO'WHS EDRETESTATN  IWH
REYO
U', OI DNG YD ANIF'T COUAN
T NDFI I C TINHETAD ARCAG,LO
SO'LSAY,I OH ", I INTHK OWKN
ING THMEINBEU'YOD ESNT IERTED
T A,"NDADY HELEOU YN  DOWA
CTTLILER RIORDO DTOIN ATYUS
K ST
ACOWD ANSHOMOU Y SE
THEREAL FUTRRESU.
MEDY'REYE  HG INTOOPE AVPELE
TECOORND A WE,THK ERHEND A TREY'
THIBLYELPF.UL
I  DK INWE WVEO RYL.EL
ANC-
SPMELE: T ASUS JT YOK U
BIOUABT  OUPCOLEGSTHF INEN  ITH
REAPIOBLGR.HY
HET  J'SUSINE:ON MF ESUT OETH
INPR
OVOUALCI CNDILNC AMEUP SRE
UTEX
ECUNE IVCOL OF
PE
RRANSYNNLV V, IA16,UMOLES
HA, BUISRG853818-13.
OUVEHA YTHEE BN THUGROH ?
AL G>>ueVEI : HAENT N'BEGHHR TOU
OUHRGHL  I'VUT B I TBEE EN
PATH
E ATS RTTHINER PTA TO
AR
LD, RE.
ANC-
SPE WH: ER F YDOOUDIN
SO
G THMEINHAKELI TT?
>>
: ue GstLYTUACAL ITH, ATINS
VATH
E OLARSS CIBGELE L,RYRA
H WH
ICR  NISEAI ERWHE ANVELI, D
E TH
OSS NUMITEERE ARTHE.
M
T I' SETPRTYATE URTHRE W'SHE I
'SGOATTH.
LOITNT P ARIRC SEDOUE.
A OFT RIIB LRAE  HESAV.IT
ANC-
SPTOYO: U  Y SOKIXNRSEA O
IS
THOO BK.
HO
WOW AYNYMA DEKA S WE YOU WLD
?RK
st G>>ueFIVE
A I'M ROI DNGCHEESAR GIF,  IO
TON IRI TP,K  W'DORY  MASANYSDA
ENASRA LHEIBREESRI APE ON.
WEWHOM'M I HRKI E WODAIV FE  A
MOA, EKSTG RTINN  8AT IETH
RNTIG INUNN'I L CAD STT ANIT
ORAN
YME.
REKE MSIELYSF E THT ERRFO
THS,HOE URTTO  NMAT, WERHA
MYENEV ITHNOINOMISG  CTOG ININ
I'OREA HD NGOT NHIPPS  IHAINENG.
LO GLLO F ERNG IOM'SIT CGIN
THT OUANS  IIFT'RKL ALWOG.IN
GOWIESHE T RYORCEAH KECAU N EP
L G INAL IY DA--AN CST-  -JU
INGE
TTN ITG  IANERTHE INGED TTG
OV OITRGNDEDIZ ANGUL MLIT I
SP.ER
C-AT: ANWHIN KD OFOOGSSWD IN
OUDO
YONAV HE JE P AROE LCTIK
TH
R  OISVEX SIARYES?
st G>>ueBOOH: , TSD RELOND A
ALO
TSS. LNDOT
SP
VEC-: AND DIERU YOEVTOAN WT
>>GIP? U
TO: ue GstCA, NOBEWAE USI JUS ST
NTREINO TENDEDST ALL R IEAY
WATE TEDO  S HLLISRYTO.
WHERTHE  DVEE RYLTFIIFCUTSOM MEN
GOU E ERYOYOINTHK EVREU' N
U  GG INTOAN AET HE DL ION
YO WD ENUPH ITA GLGBUIN
UTCO
MPH  WERITTHALL LIESE LETT
SP
MEDIITATARE  IS EMOFTIORNFMA.ON
O SOEMF  OTHOTOU Y GYEOU FR SAR
FOAGU'D ANYOCT PVERAALICLY
N OTRGTE, THEMMED ANSOEMF  OTH
T U YOGOSTYEANDAERY CAYOD U TN'
OGUFIRERE WUTHEE N  ITHDRLWO
FTHEY.IT
LTH
EYKEK OOLIBEHE TY O NGLO TA
ENFFDIERAWJIT GSE UZ PZLATD ANTH
U SHT LDOUN'HE BBEOTITNGRI WH
T EMTH AL.AL
L UN
TIT U YOGELEHAA ND, N  OITIT
VN CABEFFY ERDIULICT.
WAI
ALTE WYSRI F ARASTIR DFT
AT
ITTHVEAS H EG THRYINT,IN IND A
GLINYA RDSS UTBO ASTTEINRE
LAS
ARYND LIS
"F
DIE STIR HISD DITHHEND A THEN
JU."THD IS
LAI E  HSTAVCHA ROCALONOGIL
PPLIDRUNY  OSTYTEVF ERHANGHI TT
HAO EDEN TD M HIANE ATTH HDDI
LY EONVE DIV GEN.AY
ESON DFT AER WLIEANGATH ITTHND A
WRWIINTLG T  TTHHAUGTHROJUH ST
WHGETTOWITG  DHEONN  TAG PE,
BE AH ICISHO CRK, REMUESSHY AP
EN AN GITOEAPPR.
THUSOU Y JITGOT  WE THH OSDAN
TEYO
U M  TSTHEKED ANMATHUR SE
EY
CITHBEOR WK OUREFO YLYIN FAL
'SDEUS TDEO .THE EM
ITY EA RLLINFEA ELHEING  T
DI FHI AOR WD , LEAN B CITAN
NE KWUSCRAT , NGBUYSALI WA
ASHE
W SHE TREREEWOMHEE,OR F M
D
IM HAS ISO WINT N'GOETTOG  L
SP
ORC-: WATHMAE ERA MOC ME
AM CEO T WNG TREHILYRES AL
THTO
GE
?ER
YE: S.ue
E TH
ERWES WAA D IR TE ONON
SHI
OKBO.
AWH
ENWAOLRND COTHS E NTANMMDA
P
WINLPLAHIDE 1A HIIN8-79WHEN
D HERT CASOUGGG INPEPESHY IPN
CANINDLMAY WIOV LE  A HTHER,ND
OF HRSOUE,HE FERATEDWAR NTIM H
AVTO
H MSOE MENDEYON ASHI TNG
REBE
FOULE  HWOHELED T YMAR RR
E M;HI HS WAEASOAL L VNGDI AYER
CAHI OTY SLENGLIF VIEN  ITH
'D--TAPIL AGAR CRIESHOE RSND A
HE IOV MEDE O NTTHHITBRIS
ANCO
MM HNTDA'S AOUSE T ANDLLTHA
DED ANMAIM HRELFSE PYTT
E POUNPU-717, 78T  J9,USTEAFR
THITISHAD  OTTGOEN.UT
HTH
EYN  BADEELA PINHIALPDEHI
R
FO.YEA AR
THEYTH CPHRETUD ADILELFTIAPH A
17N 77E TTANF  OBR IWIDYNE
WEAN
D RE TREHE YOR F ANDR,EA A
EN
THGOHE TY VOOUT T ILNTLUAR
Y
NOD ANTHANERAMICCAMEACK .IN
ARCA, LDBEE HE BN EESO
ULDLBAY ATDEUND OGAR SATDANA
COID'TDN RA HOE AND
D,ELCODN IIG FHTFITHN E
B JOOFINE  GONAVE M HITH
G BE
INDAMMCOAN ONTF
RRILPHADIAPH, WAICWHH AS
TEHILEIB T A FNGOROLRND.
DEAS JFUT USAWUSBEL CAITE
PNDMAEDALITOLICN CU AMEDAN
NDCTTA AHOLL A TNG TSEHIHES
'TDI
DN AAV HE,DI INDT AV'TDN HE
AN
HI WCHY TIHETT AACT,TOD  I
D.ISHAEAHET  RKEY LLLI
UYOPC-AN JT LEMEK T USAS
RSICQUKLHAHA WT  TENPPEDHIO S
GFI?WIT FE
>>OHstue: DISH, E 17 IEDN 75
COILWHE WAAS W AATY
HETIA.ERNDOG
PH I'SN PHADILEL'S; IAHEEE BN
INWIWER RER FOTHS.YEE AR
EAHE T M TIMNTE, HUGHOH,HAE D
TECO
UR TA,D  I15NKHI, OLEA-YR-D
WN BINOSHAWHN O EDTUD RNIM H
DOY BE, TS.BODUIS
NO IHES R 38W  O, 39D ANGGPEISY
,
FET LLANHEINI , THUSK, J
OHE
ADELR VEHES.
INTHI INE SHLLFEEA H-HOVD-ERLSEE
WIOV LE , HTHIMBEOO T, USCAE
EA WHEASICHIOPSTNDEDAT AHE T
GRRAGET NELDARL NOTH, E
IOPA
TR.HET RO
I
WHANME, NOY T?
: SPC-ANHED  HLIE AVA , MPBY
IM TE?WATHT AT
ue>>
G, : stOHERS,YE V SMUY CHO.
E SPC-ANE S WAONORG LESHANR TETH
THHEOTR?
WA G>>ueWOTH: E SD UNATAATAROG
OUOBS VIDEY SLHINDS,OU AT
DNWO
ULL. H'TEA
ASHE
WTHN E ALSPHOITOR F
ME
MOSOING KE OHR TEEFOR UR
T HSNTFT AT, TERHAT ND A IULWOD
GE ATTBEERN  TNDHELD WITOU
P ENOP UAIN.
WHEIN HASAVATOPG ERTEN IOAFR
ATOP
ERD N IOAN OKITANGE BUTON
S.IP
ASIT
WGRUS JT LYIS.
E SO
LEALYHY NAFILL VT GOTO
E FO
RG E TINHEPRLYAR SG INOF
AB17 AJU, STTHE ITISWEH RE
GT OUTO O OETUTF
PH
ILIAELADPHWAAN, D ONINSHGT
JU
TSTK OKONLO AANHIT M D
TOALREIZHEHA TT OTAS W NBO AUT
LEE  BABKEO  TTAMA C AOM INDN
FITH
E D ELAN GD SOME AVHI
HILPHADNSIAPH IADTE.
SO IWEE NTE.THN ER
LO AOFLL C BHEIGIES  THE
COI ESNI, PHINTHK ADELIA
ABPR
OB T HLYADHE HHEIGST
ORPR
OPF ONTI O WRITOES, HOOF
SECO
URD HAAL HBEL ENAINAVG
REWONDL FUMETI THI WLETI BHERISH
WEHE T A FREOREA YR.
ANC-
SP WWH: ATOR AAS THAINY  TT
TI
>>?ME
A : ue GstISBRA ITATSYH MPZER,
RSPE T WONHO WUGHOHTLDSHE OU
AT NOBEPEINN DET NDENUNCOY.TR
SOHE WBRTHN E LEISITH LO, FTA T
HIOF
PHIDELALPESTOA RIWIEN WT TH
.TH
EM
OUE ONOFSO RHEEATO INST M TOKHE
ABE THT RETOEKWES UTET G O OF
ITO
WN ITHS ATHINK,000
IL
TOM IAELADPHT  WNSENHETHWI T
THNEW .RK
PHS WHE IGAMENTH C IBAE CKNTO
PHADILELD , IAANULRTPAICLYAR
RATH
E WHCADIL  TS IG--HE
VEERAMICOTAT PRITH AS,S LD WEYOU
GRHAELHE TMS WS VE--ETE ERPRTY
HAAN TTHY ATIE THEORBEHAS D EN
HNGVI ALEHTIGAI WTID MEH
RYE THBRNDH,IS A WHE TRE AAS
VEOFIN KD ANIG VILTE
WAT IHESPREADPHN IL.PHELIA
ARITY  VASERLYUG.
TELDNO S IPPEDISO NTTHASAN, D
HSAI Y,NOWAE S CTA T TANL FUMA
HEAN
D ER CTAADLYIN HO N
TIPO
LIILL CASK.LS
IK
LED WOM L, ENHEEDIK HIG
LIVINGEDHEIK BUTEAIF
USESHE LEDIKFOOO GD  AODND
WNI
CENDE,IN ASTE  HJUT  SOROF
LL
CLFETHN  IWI O L AOTESTOF RI,
INPEINUDG IPY GGSHN.PE
PNO
W,HIGYEG S FENPP'SHAHEATR D
NE
TCLR VEDEIMEDAR HNELFSE OAY W
NCORER OHETHHEBU, T N  B'DEEA
FEERSIE-TTE ND A HEND HABEIN,
FACTCONFO EDIN TE THOFATSTE
SYPE
NN BANLVIAAUTHY E IEORTHITS
RI
SUDU W TNGHEAU BARECWA HSEE AS
D ECSPTERYTO.
TE ONOFIGSEHE V WANILTEHOGSHI W
GORNTUEDBE TUTO EAHE T HHEOFD  T
RNME OF ATE THSTOFE
SYPE
NN GANLVIA IMMLOEDONN
AR
LDNOND ADEUS JT DECITHD  HATE
CLS WAA ORETOS THAANY D M,D TEHI
LYRE
ALIVON CCERU AED TEDHAE TR
THFO
R AN M.
S
HAHIASMENA WH OS JEPWHEDRE,
ABED EN-DAIN DEMPE-CAO T
INWA
SHT ONGT AGIE THBEOFINNNG
WATH
E SOANR D N. O
T
BU A WHEASR UA QKE WD ANHE AAS
CARA
DI AWHL IGWA HNDE  OHES ADF
ANRNGOE VEF NTME OLVNNPESYIAAN
HED AD MLDARE NOE L'SIF
BLSEMIRA
ORNOARLDTHISIME RYS WAVE
SHASOFT  CNDH, AALE  HRELY
IEDNEEDRDINT  OWO TERO ANO D
PERRMAY Y.GG
A WHEAS EEALRDY IAGNGEDAN
ERNU
MBIVF  OPRNEE ATMONGMAY-KI
SC
MEHEWHS H ICREWEALTH EIC ILYF
LENO
T SULLGAY  SECSPT,ELLHA W
Y.SA
GRE
ED OMMLOEDCOO NTA FLEUP O
OUESTHE NDGSIN AEDTA SRTGOS NIN
AR D ANDNDNVNGOI IGAESTISONTI
PUAN
D NGISBLHISIRO BAD TS DEINHE
NEOUR PEAB AWHT ATN OT RTEYGU
BERNCTDI AS.D OLWA
LO HSOEROL AISRN MAD IN
NT, VEWANEG INMOPE DY,ESTERA
FO
Y,MOR NEAKOT N MCHG INMU.
ESL ALTHERWOE NDHEL FUSCS MEHE
HA
T LOOFD ULADVEHA MA HIE M
Y,MO
NEHEUT B TVENER IMDEMA H
PE
Y.NN
HEAT
TTIAM SE IS HMEE NGEN SDI
Y NETON OS BTOPO STOUP ARTND
E UCEDATILE THCHF ENDR O.DR
WSEJOPH TREARN, W MHEAN HHOAD
HSE
NTTI TIMO OGNDCOERHEINA  T
FI
NOACT RSPLE.
AR HLDDLAR WKNY EWREAR AN,ND
Y WH W TINHEASLDOR WNDE  HSEGIN
THNEMOY,E CHHI H DALRELYN'IDT
HK INHE S, ADTO TPOUPRTSEHE
KI?DS
DNCOI ULUR F'TIG OTHE IS.UT
I
BI OO LKEE  SINOMHEOTR
LEIERAOGPH T AS,NDRTY HESOF O
NDREITTEGAD FOO  TA  ANOOTTE
ID,  GUEWA HSSE UC'TSN SAH
GUBA
D R AFY TE"L.AL
T
KEBUEPIT KINGNT AWE,ATG  MND A I
BUIN SPTAYIS "G,TH'TOE DSNIT F,
IWHT ATLDARS NOG RY TINTO
FIHE MLLE ?"RE
PPI SALLNAY AI, ID"WNUA T MI.TE
SUD T ORANIOUCEDATN.
ILTH'S EXALYHIHA WT ERFAS TH
FAPR TEDO FOIDOVE HIR "M.
MEI
RE TERMBEDRIT HADU TNGHE
EA
DUY RLDAYSE EF BORR,E THWA
ISNGRI HIR FRI MSTARENE AGWH
HE WHEASTR OFFN VOINADG GEYAS,
WIONAS W CY ANSTTLG ITWRIN HTOIS
OW, FEKNATG INTHASHE S WEI BNG
DUED BITCRY EDD S ORANDRRWOIE
T AB
OUAYR,HE SDOG,IN "HIS,O
, TH
ATATY PATH DIL BL,AY'TON P
BTH
ISL.IL"
BU
AIHET  S AOVD ERR  ONDVEAIAGN,
DID ANWHST F IIRTHEA RD E ESI
THND'TDN USTANIT, REE "BSU
I C OATURN LDHIRET GEEDUCEDAT.
ITOF T UTMPOT OSIM."ANRTCE
AL WHEROR O  THETHOUABT
GIBSSTMO OLYSIESVE
DNS N VEHISYLUVAE WHEMST, HIC
RTDILL R'TEAINCLE EDN,ATUCIO
PALYULICAR D-  -HECAN'IDT RE
WAFO I FITOR S OTSWNEE;AK H
'TSNAT G ARER EA RDE A GAT
LASC
HO T--R  I TUGHOHTST HAWA
THNDKI OEEQUR.
TEMIE NULI R IEAOUD ZEABTHT E
CRRWAENLDHIN REEND ANTHHTHO TUG
O CKBA TOWHIS DHCHN ILTD,OO I
LL ASUENT AS WN'ATEEQUR
THORYME.
H KISIDLL RADEABEY EN
RUAUTRMA TD ZEBYT  FHEACHEATTH T
D G HAULENBE PT D LEOUOMFR
HIDEUNR  HWHM ENA WAE S D.KI
UDIT
SBENLDEY  AN GATO UDDP.
EENWH ILARAXTPOOMD TEFRHA TT
E
OFTHEFHEOTR THCTFES T  TATHANDKI
HOHI CLDEA UODPHS L VAHAON
, OPPELEOFLOA T S HI TNGTOGABEN
SMA
KETHSEEN:  TFAE CTT HAHE
CO
E T D ULNOANOOBRK ITCRICM,IS
WATHHACTFA TASHET  WRAES DPELY
ALRI WYSORUT AEDBO, ON MEYNOT
BE MSOUCS R FOITN OWUTKESA B
HEUSCAE THEL FT EY MATONAS W A
SI THAWOTHT E GAD RLREIMEDRD H
LYHI
GH ITH, ATEDVAT LUIM H.
HE
D EE NDE T FITORAST HARE AONS
AMU
CHTHFOS R MOE SEY NEIT.LF
DE NHEEELEPED OPY O  TSA, HTOIM
ICEN"BED YT,WO'ROUE FUERL."
DE NHEEERISED CU.TY
DE NHEEENCFID NACUL IASETYRI,
ND ANHEDED CURI OTYF
USST
AT.
N' DHEID WEVT ERYBT ANANY ODTO
ARMECO AIN ANGGAAYND A S"Y, OU
ONNOE  LPRR GEA USPEOSRO
ERTR
AD. S'SON
APU YOARTH AANPOARECSY'
HECEENPRTI."
PPT ID DN'HANTWA T TEVT ERO
HAIN AENGAHEAN, D AS W
IFTE
RRATD IETHULT  IWOD.
C-
BEATANSP: MOHA WT IDNTME DE
TMECO A.ITRAOR
Gue: HEE EC BAMTOTRA AITOR
ITE THUNTE SEDTAINWIS THWO T
EKS  HISNGED WDIGGO  TPEY
N IPSHPEE ENWH HE OTA .TTLEER
ENHE
SANT MI EINARSSY  NTOEW
THRKFFERS G INHIESRVSEIC TO
ISBRE ITH.
ANC-
SP YWH: ATS R EAWAISTH?
C- G>>ueOFMA: Y 77 18.
>>WHANSP: S E ERWA?HE
: ue Gst I WHEASN
ELILPHAD.IA
TI'SHE SMA CLLOM JANNDT,TUS
IEMA
RRD.
SE
ET ANT L SR TETO HEN
MMINCLTE , THHITBRIS
CICOINDEANR- IHI-CEFYONEN W
C-.TY
TTHOANSP: HEDIW D HAET G TT
GLEHI TERO M?
AL>>THstue: S E ERWAACHA IN
DEED NERAMEPOSH URANSTSB
Y
NGLI
VIN  IELILPHADHOIAPH WAS W A
ORRVPUEYNEF  OFI THI CNAO
ADPH
IL HPHELIACIH IGSOY.ET
OB
THSLVIOUGY PY,EGENHI SPPNE KW
. GISUY
SH WHEASOR TY.
YW HMUE STOWE AVKN.THN AT
ANCA, AYI LIT N'BEATE EVTHHE S
'TDI
DNHIEL TL TOHOM W ITEN SD ,
SHAN
D D WOE ULAVSOAL H HTOE LDIM
O
WHD  STOEN W TITO,ASCHHI WOT N
SSNE
CESIILARY Y HER NRF MSHIEL--
W
ETITAVLDOU H HBEE EN GD ARTO
WH HTOIMTOBU- T  JAJ MORDRN OHAN
SIWAO S Y'HER NR-DAIS DECAE-MP
ANTH BD,Y  AWAE Y,H HOLTUGEYTH
TIY MANOVEHA INO KWNHEATT  T
SMEHESI, R Y'NRMASPS Y ERST.
SORYNSTABUTOET GS OREW N YK
OFD O ESGO TITETME W AANH DRND
RNRSFE ASED'OLS , ICRVESDAN
RROMFR THEONN  TS IRE
ERCOENPOESNDCE.
CKBALEARE E THERTTS T  WATEN
FOAN
D H.RT
EREYTH WWRALE L INTEITN IP CHER
H  WORITLINEINR HANGNI TUYOT
LEPU
T ICN MOJUR ONE  OVELDHE OR
A
CAND OTHSOR METOING IN FD
IT
TH.
REE ERWEUSAR VIOEROU CRIANS D
WE-BGOET TS ENASNG THEHIONEN WT
8 EROV 1.NTMOHS
C-WHANSP:  B DATIDT EDENICNOARLD
E K ASTHH ITBRISR?FO
ue>>
G: stST FHEIRTHAI SD AT
AT
MEWHWAE NTDO TEDO USAS W JTOT
HECOVE OR.
BED AN WTEE  CTOOMNDEROV A
BMECO A MTIRISHENORAJ GALER.
INI
THROHEK  PTHBLBAY THGHOUT AT
AT
THLDOU B ASUE CHBLER TRIE,
THVADESTSYG INPOLCH BICOGALWLO
FO W TATHEMELEHO AWACARIN R
ULEFLD WRTOULERU CMBEND A H
ITCOTHWID N FOWAE R THR E
ABRH.IS
ODHEY UACTLLMED HASOGOER VY
S ID
EA T HOFOWTHWIO N FOWAE R
TH
ISBRE ITH.
HEIF
TSTD Y'LIEDEN T THIO M,
YHE
EYGHMIT . WVEON
EYTHNOAI SD .
TETH "AI SD,E'S,YE WY VREER
IN.STREED
ITH
ISERWOS NDUTL,FU BULT  IWOD
BE
MOUC MH FU URESES TOL  UTO
HA S YVEOUERY TAWHARYOE U RFOE
MOTH
E NTME.
NDSETES  UINCEIGLLENIFND A, OU Y
GCA
N,OMET CF NDMA O OWIA NG
F
ARTH
WET E  ANDAKE HARESU T
.T GEIT
ETOR
GNDOM CMA IF  OANNTORMPTA
ST AE  MNDAKHARESU TWET
URCA
PTITE .
BU
BOS LET T'BOLKTA AS, TUTHIREA D
"Y.
TO OATNEERNTOI HLDARE NORO WTE
ENIR S HNT CRYLI S AONNDD,AI
F "ILLU YOWIMEEL TL PLOU YR SAN
FO
COTHR E AMNGMI CIGPA TN,N HEI
E LLWI BLE TSENDOROU Y ME
RIPRAPOPFOE ATINN,ATRMIOAN" D
HESI
R Y NRBAOTWRE  M VCKIAORAJ
AN
LL S ADRNDI D,AI "HAN'DOT  TVEO
U TENYOU Y AINTHG.
YOINSTJU FASOUD T UC MASH OU Y
U'CA
YO O TREHE A WNEHOHEROPPACD
W , USNOU PRE YO, SEURLFDAN
MTH
ENE'BEAY WK  TLLALWHOUABT AT
GU'YOREO NGOI T."DO
LDAR
NOOU CSTN'LDT D ANIT
CA
EXBEF E,US O, URCOSEASATTH W
THTLACY HEWAE Y THEL FT  HATIS
COOW
N ENTRUNYMTRER WE TIEANG
HI
NT T AM,NDT'S ACTLHEWHY Y
ITWAGO TEDO TOVE OR HE T
BRH.IS
HI ISO TS  TNKHI L WISHYNERAT O
M PHEUTNDORAJ AEOINR  JRDPAY
DED ANENETUPD  GAJNGTI MR AORND
EDHA
NG.
INI
THELHEK  DELERIBATDIY D A
DRUPCOLEGSTHF INPUHA TT RMAT JO
ANFES  'LIN THLINE.
ANC-
SPR MA: JOASDRAN WD AN HGEBY
OMWH?
ue>>
GNG: stHA BEDAMTHY E ICERAN
AR F, MYINF NTRO OMYE THART A
ANTA
PPSEEC BAUS E  HWASPA Y.
C WHEASBEGHAUT INNDHI L IESN
UIDI
SG.SE
WHSPC-ANTED ANAFADPHR IL,PHELIA
E DIBENERNCTDI A?D OLGO
ue>>
G F: stHE RALINLYD IGESNEAS
ANCO
MMANNTDA,  HTHD ENDID
GI
BEETTON  GR.ET BTE
RSHEALES ABINAL T ARIO DE
GOHO B AE,ND TTHY IS WE IMHEAS
D NEG ATTIINHETHWI TSHRI BTI,
ANS  TBYHIHEMETI TSHRI BTI
ERREWE VREINY TEN EDST ISTWE
T.PO
IN
SP
GC-ER: ANWHESISE  WT?POT IN
>>ITstue: BA P'SRO MY BL50ESIL
H NO
RT Y NOFEWTYK ORCIHEON,  T
ONHU
DSIV R.ER
HUTH
MOALST RDSONERIVOE GS
IGST
RATH NHTORW F  ONEITRKYO CY,
THAN
D GO IENT OU TESHRSE TGHHE
E RISEESSCCOF RKRNW RETUNDARS OU
THD ENUNMOTAAL CLE
LAHI
GHS.ND
IT
SAY, V'SERDIER VY TICFFUL
SSANINILG CO OD,F THSEUR, E
VE TS ELINAYSEHO D'TDIS DN
W,NOSA AS LLWE AO RSOU D
.YWANAY
OR ISON  GR DETOIV UETPRER
H ITBRISHAIPSHS  GD TOTHO UGROH
HITH
E S,LAGHNDHEND A TCAME ARINS
PUHA
D CHA AISSACN ROEN  ITH
ODDMILEHITHF E LAGHRLS NDEARIE
HEIN
THIAR W W B TCHHE HTIRISHAD
BE
E  AENBLAK BTORE
.
HESO
TE CHY OSOISTWE P T FNTOR
HE
BENE TLA PCEPUO AIA T CHN
THTHUSCAE  AE ERISRVS-N CUE
E.ER
AIT
'S18OSLMT EEDE0 GR TS,HE
RS
FI OPAT RTANITF , THD E
H ITBRISNOULWOD BLBET  ATOE
K BR
EAAIE THCH A TN,HETUMRGEN
WE
CA, NTBE TE USINRS CHEOUOFE
TKIMANGRNT HATUWOHE TY VED ULHA
ESTO
RIR TETHE AAI SLSND
UAVI
RTOPY LLST T INATHE WD, ERAN
EN
THWOHE TY  HDNUL'TE AVTHE
UMMEMONTEAO  TBRE K THAICHN.
SIANMEWHHIE, WHELE TWEY RE
L THINTTG E ASITTCKG INDUS,
ALTTE THBAUPIEERS STT  AWE
T PO
IN AUPBOTH OVEN FBLE UF
TULWOD TOBL AE  TLA BSTTM HEOU
OFER WHEAT
T SO
IRYS WAVETAMP IORST, NTWE
T,PO
INE O  TTHANERAMICEGTR SATY
K
OF TPIEENGTI BHERI O OSHUT
F
E THDSHULE VONALPRANY D NGECOTTI
MATH
E SS CINROING,IN KRRS G'FEY,
H WH
ICFES WAA S MIW LE TTOHE
SPUTSOH,ASCHHI WNGHITON
ADEY ATEREL.EDNEED
STSOANOLRND Y PED GGER AGOFT
WE, OI PNTE D ANSHNAMAS GEA
LIFE
W INLETT FS LIAGNG HONER
NDN,OW AD RN AOLOEENTH GANS D
INRE
JOINWAS SHONGT.
HE
AS HENT N'BESERO PMIETITD  Y
BU
THET 'SD OLTHISBRE ITTHH AT
I HHEAS H AT,ND GTHE ENS OETO
EY TY. AHERM
D THJUER WE OS ASTCRHUTHS E ONDS
OUANLELIA TTORIT B NGU, THI SES
ARPA TNDAPCH WN,HIERS  IWHE
ETH
EYP EDND UWEFEA W TES EKLAR.
ETHE
GE THS ERSHD ANWAGTINON
YS
SA"W, E L,EL WF RTSO ODANCHGE
OU
STR .TERAGY
REWE
A GOTOIHA TNGO  AVEN
IN
CTIACVEN,PAAMIGHEND A TFORERE
NOI'
M G GOT INE  GTOIVSTU YOWE
T.PO
IN
'R
ANWEG GOE INAC ATOTTYONEK W ,RK
NTI D WAO OU Y THEADLE TEF LT
OWI
NGE F THMYAR."
IS
ND A TAS W AFIERRIR,HOC NO
FUNOARLD BT OROFEDSH A
ND ALEMBD PESTD AMNDARD OU
COIDSA, ESL,EL Y OSI, R,
BSEUR,"N  TUTHEXTE THNEAY D
INWA
SHOTONGT GLINT IELNCE
T AB
OURIMESO BOVSHTI MENEMTS
TH
E  MATADLLM HICAFF T
TA
TUATNE OCKN  WYOW RKCHHI
OFACLYALANER WE ECND IIRRET SU
INOM SE IGLLENCET  THANOARLD
HED HASE NN  ITOK. YEWOR
SAD AL CLEF THATTA ACKND
INF , ID"IALU YORET  WLYANSTWE
PO BTHT ATI'LYAD,  GIVIT
OUTO
Y T A,"NDWHT'HAS GO HENE T
ON, ITAU 3ST.
MAMBEP STEHE 2ER1 ET MIT WH
DRR JOAN F A ,NDYSR OUDAAT LER
SOE THWHG THE INEWBL.
S E  HWALEERTHE N  TSSHATWO
.NTMOHS
OKSPC-ANISERTHE T  P AAR TOFHE
BO YHE WREK  TOUALGEOUABT GEOR
GTSHWAINI CONOMSE TNGO E
DIBE
NEOL ACTRNESATD  WT,POT IN
THAN
D GE HENE  O OTSUTE.THF ER
st G>>ueTH: AAZS T'AMING.
MADRR JOANEEAD H BURCAN PT.ED
HAN
DRE  CADOMR RIUPVETD ANME
RNTHWI ANDD,OL AD RN AOLTD HAPU
TOM HIINIOOS PITE WHN ER HHEAD
HIO  GBERI ANDMENEN CALIANS D
E WH
ER T HHEADN BEO  ISESGDIUI.
BRS S HIT NTCOACTHWIHE T
CKBAISITH,TH HNDE S  GENOE
EWTO
NK, YORE UT B H GS HATOO
NDEROVLASEEC BAUHIIS H SHAP S
DGO
NEERNROWIV.
C-'SIT AORG ONST A BY,UT..WANYY.
ANANSP: BRTHD E COISITH RONTL
ATMA
NHN.TA
ue>>
GE : stTHH ITBRISLNTCORO
ATMA
NHN.TA
BASTWECHUNR TECOIC, TYWHISH
ANTNDSILLN TWBEEEOISTWE P
ATMA
NHS N,TA IF RTSO OANNOA -M
LA
LONT, NDCO BLLROEDNOY BOTH, DYWI
A OVOFT  RNDG INBAOFS
ITREIRGUBO ORSN ES STHID.
A'SDAER VY EROUTERRORITY,
JOT BUTHERS  IWHLDARE NOEN SDS
NMA TANR DRMAO KEAYIS H WAC BK
SOTOK. YEWOR
IRISND AR EDTO SPPMEY  BSO
RSGURELA.
OU CLDTAAV HE ISEDLK HUTAY W O
T OF
IEAITQUE RELYSI, BULYAL, T
N' DHEIDK THT INNOSTFA EH.UG
F EYTH MTAHIE M  HICLOTSHE
OFY  TSOHESEULCOD IMCHAR H,
INAN
D OOIS H B FTHT EYLANDOU PNS
FO
NOTHR E TAWE OCKN NT PSTOIN I
AIARAN'SLD HNGRIDWTIWH, ICH
AGARN LDNONSAD H ITHTEISD
AKDRAN T TBAE CKYONEO W  WRKHIT
M.
E TH
ER RS WANOFOSOEAN TOHIR M
ARBE
CTHINRYG ANE OSPLS.
LD CHEOUMEAV HE D RIMOZEATTH
LYEA
SIARBU, T NSLDNO IITTEISD
USBE
CAANHEE  WPAD TEA AIR PETRL
ROTO
PT  WVEHA D HHEAD TE ONTOHE
ISBR
ITETTOH  GIS MEY,
I
K.TH
IN
T
HE T, YWANAYGUESTHE ND FYSOU
RSPA
PEMEAN, D E WHANILASDRAN W
HA
BEERNGVI VISFOY OLY.HL
ASHE
WG,AY SIN GI' "LLU E IVYO
GO
GOE ."LDATU'F  IYO M LLLET
, WE
LLASATTH WUCOO T MH.
ANI
ME STH, EY GEHOMOW WINOF
TH
PO TFAE CTEYT HATHOMAD H SHIETNG
IMONANRTT  HHE TIRSODSAN,
TTH
EYHINEURD  TOVM ERTHO E
ANERAMICNDOM CMATH OERF LOE CAL
PO T WSTHOUTNSUR OVEO  THAEE BN
RRRAA THHEUL ME-NDEDAD AOT N
TTELY BGHWHMAT N EDLOO OK
ATOCSEHE D AENUMTSOKD NLO AEDT
R MA
JONDDRAN A "AI SD,ARESTHE E
G
IN AERENALSOLRND'
WRHA
NDG,IN" HEICWHH
RE
I EDGNCOIZ."
I'ESGUS ERBED TTTHEN SD E
DOCUTONTMES WAEN G. ONINSHGT,"
TO WHATINS HIPOONWAT S AYIS H W
FBA
CKNNM ROCOT TIECCU THE
IN
MAINRM AY N,AP TPARKEW NYO.
ADHE
HOVEE BN CO IERN CUECNNTIT
INME
ET TWIG THNC FHERE H AH,NDE
HS WAON B WISAYK.AC
THOT IISDIN  IESSTWECHUNR TECOTY
, SA
YSOI'M"I GSE TNGO  TNDHE
PERAPENTOS  GASALER WN,NGHITO
E CABEUS OHEUGSE THTO ETHE ES
GUD ANFI W OREUTGOT'HAS ,G INON
. T BUMEI ILWHE ENLLWI SYOD U,
MRNDHNJO A" SOERN,WAICWHH S
"UE THNAANHA TT  U WDRASNGSI,
Y TOP  MDEMMCOANHEANR D AN C
SPOSOF YHE AOUS IL WL."
NOS HICOWADEANR DIBES NECT
SAARD , LDANHODRAN TE HTUG HSWA
SOD.VE
GHT  IWARKA S DATOND A SYRM
NI IT,LIEENDD Y,RATELLHE WN
R MA
JOASDRAN W OAK TENHIN S
RS
HOWIE UA ATH GTO URDP RDWAS
PWESTNTOI.
WH
E IL'SHES N  OHINTY,WA ITHO E
T ID
IODEMMCOANADS R'HERSARQUTE A
W
ISFEBELEMIS ERW LOWH IANE DRATS
TH -OI PNT IAN- DRINHES ADG
STNORT C THE IRIOUERHES GINAD
EAO  T FY TRTOSHD INWAGTINON
THWI TAPHE P AS ER--O  INDNTETH
JOHET'IOS TEQUADARME RSCOAS
BEMARAOFR  DCAONGOS EDLL
THAMINALLMGEADHO W
CAREEOTIS Y LLWAETH
BT,UTCEFI TR TOIOS HIID
R MA
JODGLLTAMA HALE SOD PEAPNETO
T
BED  HHEEAER GOFENAL
GTSHWAINEC'SON SRVT RESEE.IC
HWH
END HEE ARTHOUABT RSPAE PE
D
ANARHET ABD OUHIATWH TMAS N
DOHA
D  S, NEHEYOD,AI "HICRU ASNG
ID
T!IO
D Y WHDI TU YODOBVS?HI O,USIOLY
ISERTHE HIOM SETNG GNGOIN O
."HE
RE
I
OFHED ISNSTE HTHATER SISUPRIO
AJ MORFIR,, FAN CTORNDSE F
AAN
TUTHE BNDRIIMNG H BAC BK,
INMA
N  OSTSIEDINSEN NDHEANG OT
R
IECO
URHEONR  ATO UADP D RN AOLTO
HTE
LLT  WIMHAPPD HAHAED.
AN
CKME WILWHE,TOHIASNGOMISN  CGIN
BADIY  BA T ERFFEN SUTROE,
WAE THPA'T DRSON UAT CCHTOP
ONINSHGT.
ARBU
T ITLDNO SWNS DOO T
KFBR
EAE T ASTHORXTNE MNDNGNI A
NOWSGE ATEETR  TFROM D GHEUY
W BE
LO, YISANGVEE "WHAREAP CTUD
NDHNJO ACASOERN YIRRNG
IMIN
CRG ATININ, PEPARSED ANTH
RSPA
PEBEAV HE T  SENENER GTOENAL
GTSHWAIN."ON
ANHEUT NTHS ATDOOTE  G AWNNDETS
YINOHEOTR ED ITEMMTELY,
SAEN, NG"GASALER WN NGHITOIS
ISON
HERAY W HTOE FARE BAK."ST
ASHE
WTIXP EEC F HNGIMOR
BR
T KFEAASORATTH MNGNI.
S "H
E'INAMEXINW A G FETSDOREUB
BOUP
AE, HVEERND AE' H BE RE
IN
NONU0  1MIS.TE"
OVAR C, LDOF TRSOUE,NKHIITS 'S
ER.
KAN, S E "HHAPATHE RSPE.
'SHEWSNO.
HE TOI GNGMEGEO T ."
WHHEACTA UEDPS HS IRTOE, WISIF
ANHAWAO S RENGVI B IFAAKSTBEN D,
RYS TED LLWHR ATPE H'SAPDNE
VELYUI QCKESDA, SHOW DS,TANSIR
ONMPJUS ORIS H HES, SEGOEO  TTH
BOF OMTT OLLE THHI JNDUM IPSN
RGS HIBAE.
HAR AAS B WGHITEIT
ARGBAEMTHOW DN CAE ERBEE USHE
ISS OSTHR RIE VEESOMFR WT
T,PO
ING IV LINOU AIN H T OSEFFHE
PO
T.IN
STH
EYO RTTA T TW ROUPAROWDS
WE
OIST PD , NTANS, SHEAYNO ",
IDYO
U DOTSIO, R,RIWNVEUSBE" CAE
HIHE
TATS NKTHHIHE T STHP AT
BRMAGHOUT DRR JOANERPR UIVS I
ABPR
OBTI WLYAI H FNGORN  DIMOW
TRVEHARS,  BAWAYS D ANHILYON
TANCHCEINGEF TT IAWG AYETTOS  G
TOIPT HASH.
ER OHERDTHS EMW,O  TROHEND A TY
D,RO
WEUR F IIG I, EDANBLRENCDIE
-OUAMNTAUMY-  DUSTEGHR BE TEDO
R,ROA WEE ND A WD GUFIRETHT OUWI
--S TIE DE HR FOAND R OUANHAA LF
ND G HIM SHE TREELAFY,
INLE
AVY PEG GG.HIBEND
HE
O OT G TIPE THSHAMND A CINE
HEDEUNR  WGUR NSWHH ITA AGE ITFL
ON AOR LITE TLWHKEHAE NDHIRCEF
HE TF OP T OYOS HIBAT.NE
SPC-: ANISTH BAS W A STIRISHP.HI
ue>>
GIS: stTH BAS W ASHRITI
HEIPT.RI, GH
THOL TD LEPEE OPN  OWHARBOD AT
EYD HAHAEDEN.
FOTHSIER WE G INTHITE ERWAGIN
R MAR JO ADRAN ,Y  TNDHEIDSA,
IHE"WREWOTHN E  HD RLIS"E?
SAN
DRWED,AI "'S, LLHEEE BN
PT
GOCA AEDUR,"HEND TSAY,OHMY,
S  TD,HIRI TISERE."
HFOBERE, LEE FT TFOBEREYHE
BILSAEDWNK ACDOO  TNEW YO,RK
LDAR
NO ARO WTER ET LTEER GTOENAL
INWA
SHWHONGT, HIBYO  T HTIS MEAD
T
ATOT TENER PHEAPD ANDIKND OW
ICWHAPAS W H, NIPENGERLEA TT
WHN,BEH GAHETH "E ATT ARTHS I
CICO
NS IS OUOF R OTSWNDETIECTU
CA
TTOTNN AO PTEM TTELLPAIA A
HIEPST W W TCHHEAYLDOR MREEN CSU
ROAS
W."
GUTH
E D Y HAUTCHF A,ZP ITHNOING
SE
NEL.
HEDMEREV ATEIT HTHD ATDHAE
HENEDO AG THINONWRG.
S WAAV NERD ITDMTEE ATTH H
TOTR
AIR.
N
HEDMEREV AANTEITD , HIYTNGTNO
L UN
TIY E THDAD. DHEIE
ANC-
SPDIBE: NEOL ACTRN TWED NT
O
ANEN
GL?WHD EN
st G>>ueENHE: WTOT OREW N YK
HEFIT.
WEHE TN AN ONTN EDXPITION
THFO
R ISBRE IT TDOH WNO
VI
D , INRGIA TD ANHENTN HEWEP U
N,DOEDTAATCKONEW N L
ECCO
NNCUT.
NT WHEENLA ETONGOU AND CE PLOF
CEMOER AHSFTOWOR YKT IN,N
DEF ERMB OAN8117, OTHED  G
E TH
ER JANRY.
OTHE
GNDO  TLOJA IONN ARY
.17
C-
IVENNSP:  DLOW NGLI HIDE
ANEN
GLD?
G
>>stueUN: 01L TI18STAL, MO0 2
YE
S.AR
MI
CAA RASEE,BLABIS MER 2LESYE0 AR
BEE E USTHITBR'TDIS DNIK LE
HEM HIEI.ER
AS W AD AI FLER.AITRTO
WTH
EYT LDOUN'IMVEGI H J AOB;
EY
THN'OU WLD HGIT VE A
SIMMCOISTH IONN .ARE MY
FOG RH WDON'LDT INNY ATH
HHI
TOY GO TADO NAO  TCATR TDAO
MST SEHI AF ELUPRCA S MENDNTHA A
, ADTRERATD ANTHT ID DN'RKWO
OU
T.
ADHE
HIS A MABER TLEE.IM
C-
NTHANSP: WE HENE CA TNTO DANA
>>--OTA OVSC?IA
: ue GstUNW NEBRICSWK.
: SPC-ANIDU YOSAD E  HHAA
SSSTMIRE.HE TRE
FES HIWIT AS WN'IMTHWI H?
st G>>ueSHNO: , 'TWAE SNIT WH
FOHI
ARLEF FITHR E UPT RSCO
SPYES.
MIC- H: ANHEAB AAD BHEBYY  T
?RESTSS
SO GstADHE:  HLEN  AILTETIGIMA
C-E,THN ERES Y.
>>BUANSP: WIHIT S ND FFEOUUT O.
HE Se GstI LLWE, SHINTHK
TOAVE.
N  THEHEO NTWE TD GLENAND ANGOT
ANHE
R OTTHD E DSR HEKI.
IT
CA TAS W AY TO.
I LIT N'BEE E EVSH FDNDI'TDIN
T.OU
N'I
DO TKNT OWE T HASHUTD,DI B
CA
LIT N'BEE EVE SHDNDI'T
ANC-
SP YWH: ATD R EADI? DHEIE
ue>>
G01: st18.
GSPC-ANT? WOFHA
BA>>YOstue: , KNU OWIS IS
EMNGASRRSISEEC BAU A G IOT
ORDO
CTLLO  TTEATE  MWHE H
T OUTHGH,  WITASHEOMFR T
PONTCOEMRYRAIPES DCR AONTIS, IND
CANO
W MET N'REERMB.
EYTHAL C AD LEITALEN GERYRO DPS
A AN
D E SEDIAS L TINHEGSUN.
W
SPITIO OASBVOMLYUS SHIETNG
DOREY,ATIRORE ND A H'TULCODNIE L
G AWNNDFO CETOM.ABRTLE
K THI IN S WITASNGETOMHIEN  ITH
S,LU
NG CUT B IEM'TAN RNOBEEMR W.
SP
ISC-AT: ANWHU O  DYOOFINTHK
THUY G?
ue>>
GTH: stI  WK INHE AAS
INTTROEN, ITRAOR, SEMYLFT BUI
TH AHEK 'SEL HNOFL  A
REIN
TEINST AMAG N,RFON WDE
AR
CHTEACR.
EXFEI ELORRYOR FN IM H IWAA Y,
HIHAPTCE TROHET  BT HTUG I
WELMSF.
LFHEAL TASOTKI LLYAC I
SEEDNO-KWLGE.
VEU YOHAVEO  THAOM SE
ASCO
MPI ONSI,  FINTHK, A
PE
ONRSEAHO W RY LL TISALOTLY
-DSE
LFUDEL AEDUTBOIM HNDLFSE A
OU
ABWOTHT E D RLO D ANWHESDON'T
ALT LERE AY ITINALT L.
IT
IT I'STIERNTES.NG
VE V N'SOTMIY ERAD BBLRAE, YUTOU
HAVEO  THATL L AITM SPE ASOF
HPI
TYD E ERANFOERTHE  IHIR M,
THINK.
ANC-
SPISIN:  HHORYTO,  HDOW ESE
FI
OWIT THER OURTHORRA TIT
ue>>
GDO: stI INT N'THOEHEK  DS,
YALRELYELRYVE WL.
IFK  LOUOO C TATHED OLRWA
TAITRTOEATH, E ESY RLONTA , LO
OFM HEOIREWE DFO INGT R
INLOCAL S,ASREON DND A I'TON
THLDARK NON AD H AGIEOIDLOLCA
IBO
NEBOHIN S .
INI
TH MHEK 'SOSH UCCL TERO
ME. MR AS.
THI INMOTHK E ESY NEQUSONTI I
CMU
CHSELOR.
WO
MRI  BDNUL'TRISUE RPD SEIF
RY DAM. ESALN'IDT  HAVSOME
RFOE PVE, RYL SOERNAS ASREON
IFVIHANGE ONISTH.
EAOU Y RTTA D LI T BLEITTHA
E WE
'VENL ALBENGEA RDI HBO AUT
CA
A ER, CAN ERE SEWHE THE ER
ENTMT,LOOFINAPISPO
IBPO
SS
.LY
PATHI INMAERTHE OMBEY  S
SOS.LLRAEL
E ALAMMR, .  GOTN TOTHH UCWI
THNSSSRUIAAMHE T S HYEE ARE
MAWA
S TOIERRD ECIS H SUCD,ON MH
UNGEWI.FE
SPC-ANHE: ATIE DD 0.GE A 6
DIHO
W EAHED  L W HVEISDE IFAN
DS.
>>
RS: ue Gst DIN TT EBUPRTHO EI
EAVI-  -LIA  INGN ANGRD,
LA
SHVI WOU HSEWIH ITA ELNE CRLA
D ANTSRVSEANHEND A TAR CRIEAG
BYD ANHO T AESNDLE WHEHO.HI TNG
WATIHI TS IR TMEHET LD OESNSO
NDINS  ITH IIAN MYE ARBU, T
HEE THOTE  WRSER QALRELYTEUI
G.YO
UN
WEERTHE EE TREHRBOOR ME  AYSND A
GI
ANRL.
UC AMRD S. POLRND,WHGYEG, HAO D
STBYK LLIM H AHI T ATIS MEND
NEHA
D MIR VEADO EDTT TYBANODY
TTH
ATASREHE WINNY ATHTHG E
TT
STMA -ER- LLE SHCA T HEDIMHE
BESBF  OHU- DSAN -OKE SHTO
SOLDHO,  TSOE LDSE HHEOUESH,
W TLDHELLE INCEE , ARSHTPU
TH
E WHE OLUPINTHG UCOR F AONTI,
HTBO
UG T F AEWBANGHIS CK
ELHE
RSAB EF,ST HSHLIED ISEERLFN
TI
A TT, NYLISE HLEOUYAN  OBRONNS
ETST
RENO, AGAR CRIHO NE,O ESRS,
IETHNOIN LRO WTE TTEETRSHEO R
FRYIS NDSAHE, NG"T ARERE
BEOPPELEE  HHOAVNUENBE SMEINBBG
I USCAE N'DOHAT T  WVEHADII D
EFVEHA BNDE,OR A CAN ARREIV
HEAT
T P TIREA ITIARESN
RR
KNCA BGEIAS,WH SUTO AT.
I  M WOWHO FREY ALENRI ADSRE
W,NO DND A IAV'TON HA E NGSILE
VE IN OUISTH HT  TSEHAI
SHHAIDT N'PAYSOR F MF.EL"
MAE GENATOD GERR AANLLOR F A
TH
CHE DRIL TENBEO TEDU ECAD.
T E SHGOUNE THYOYSR GEBONT IO
ANLIMITAMICA ADE T AESNDNGHIS
AN GTHD EN COTCEANHEOFR  TOM WB
ADID EDHRUTBO TFO OEER UR
AFARYES  DR TEHEID.
T BUE SHS WAMESOOM W -ANT,SM- AR
UGH,ERLLINY TEENIGT.
NDA
WOLAFUERL .
C-
WEANSP: OUE 'RABOFOUT T IM TE.
U N CAYO ULLS HIATWH TS?MES AN
ue>>
G, : stOH MATTH'SANHUY SBD
MYAN
D  CHR TEELDHIN.RE
SP
C-Y : ANWHU D DIYOWI IDOT TH
ERLE
TT
G
>>I stue: KNN'DOT .OW
N.R FOFU
ICA
RLUSMYS  HCANDBA, ISROMEN
MY
ARONTE SPSCOAN, D N LIAND ANDIA
SPMYE  S D AONNDR.GHAUTE
C-E : ANARINU YOGORITOG  WTE
R OTANHEOKBO?
C- G>>ueYOOH: , BEU T.
>>ABANSP: ATT OUWH?
: ue GstRON RR AND
ANAL
EXMIR DEHAONLT.
WANTOWO  TKN TBO AUTELT HADU
HESP: ANHERES  ITHE OKBO.
"T MAN IN E THMIRR" ISHE
IDTSOMEF CLAN, D ANE ARBR
THE THAU.OR
TIT
'SE  LHEIF BOFEDENT
AR
THLDNO.
U K ANYOUCRYVE M